donc
le temps que tout le monde sort monsieur
le ministre chers collègues nous avons
le plaisir de vous accueillir pour la
première fois dans cette législature
mais certainement pas pour la première
fois en commission des lois vous étiez
un habitué de la précédente législature
et avec cette deuxième audition nous
poursuivons notre cycle qui était entamé
la semaine dernière par Christophe Béchu
pour la présentation de la feuille de
route des différents ministres
concernant votre ministère les sujets de
manque pas vous avez mis en œuvre des
réformes structurelles vous préparez une
loi qui d'orientation et de
programmation du ministère de
l'Intérieur dites Love Me vous êtes en
charge la petite migratoire de la
réforme de la police judiciaire des
réflexions sur l'autonomie encore ou
dans les autres mers avec des urgences
quotidiennes à gérer on a vu cet été
notamment les incendies de forêts la
multiplication des refus d'obtempérer
j'aurais une question sur cette question
la persistance des
urbains et ce ne sont il a ici bien
évidemment quelques exemples
la Commission est loin et je tiens à
vous le dire en même temps pour nommer
les rapporteurs des différentes missions
d'informations à choisi de créer trois
missions d'information je commence par
celles qui vous concerne moins puissiez
le concert le ministère de la Justice
qui sera donc rapporté par Monsieur Jean
Tellier et Madame Cécile intermeyer la
commission des lois a créé une mission
d'information sur l'évaluation de la
mise en œuvre du code de justice pénal
des mineurs pour les deux missions qui
vous concernent la commission des lois a
décidé la création d'une mission
d'information sur la réforme de la
police judiciaire dans le cadre de la
création des directions départementales
de la police nationale
expérimenté dans cinq départements
métropolitains et dans les départements
d'outre-mer les rapporteurs seront
monsieur Hugo bernalicis et Madame Marie
guévenou sur cette question vous aurez
peut-être quelques éléments à nous
apporter monsieur le ministre
la Commission des doigts enfin a décidé
de la création de la mission
d'information sur les enjeux de
l'utilisation d'images de sécurité dans
le domaine public dans une finalité de
lutte contre l'insécurité et cette
mission d'information a été confiée au
rapport de Monsieur Philippe laton et de
Monsieur Philippe Gosselin donc
naturellement ces émissions
d'information commence dès à présent
elle dureront une durée maximale de 6
mois et une durée indiquée de trois mois
je relancerai moi-même les rapporteurs
pour qu'on ait des rapports qui soient
rendus dans les délais nous allons
procéder à votre audition je rappelle
que la durée des questions est de 2
minutes pour tout le monde dans le cadre
de ce type de d'audition et
j'aurai moi-même avant de vous poser une
question la nomination d'un rapporteur
sur un texte de loi pour lequel vous
n'êtes pas concerné qu'il a proposition
de loi examinée par le Sénat visant à
actualiser le régime de réélection des
juges consulaires dans les tribunaux de
commerce pour lequel j'ai reçu la
candidature unique de Madame Clara
chassagnol pour le groupe Renaissance
et donc je procède à sa nomination
je vous disais donc que nous avions des
questions j'en ai réponds à part mille
si je ne devais pas les sélectionner et
donc j'en ai retenu quelques-unes la
première vise notre travaux
parlementaire immédiat qui seront ceux
de la loop me qui vous concerne une
loopnie par laquelle vous avez annoncé
la création de 8500 postes de policier
de gendarmes d'ici 2027 en indiquant
notamment 3000 d'entre eux seront créés
dès 2023 et donc je voudrais que vous
puissiez nous préciser dès à présent la
ventilation de la création de ces postes
entre les services de police de
gendarmerie la préfecture de police de
Paris les tâches qui seront prises
prioritairement affectés à ces agents et
puis les villes naturellement qui
pourront en bénéficier je voudrais
également avoir une pensée au nom de la
commission des lois pour le policier qui
a été grièvement blessé hier à Anzin
vous nous disiez devant la commission
des lois que c'était un refus
d'obtempérer toutes les 30 minutes qu'il
y avait lieu dans notre pays que ces
refus d'obtentes préférés ont porté
gravement atteinte à la santé de
de nombreux de policiers gendarmes donc
je vous puissiez nous préciser si votre
doctrine a évolué par rapport à ses
refus d'obtempérer quels sont les
consignes données aux policiers qu'elles
peuvent être par ailleurs les victimes
civiles et par ailleurs quel est le
résultat aussi sur la protection des
policiers des gendarmes quant à
l'évolution de cette doctrine c'est ma
deuxième question ma troisième question
concerne les migration et la quatrième
le concernant également nous avons dans
nos permanences de plus en plus de chefs
d'entreprise qui ne sollicitent par
rapport au manque de main d'oeuvre que
nous vivons dans notre pays et qui se
décide par ailleurs des régularisations
pour des agents des salariés des
indépendants qui travaillent pour leur
compte et qui se trouvent aujourd'hui
empêchés puisque nous régularisés ou
sans papiers je voudrais savoir quel est
votre position par rapport à ce déficit
de main d'oeuvre et par rapport au
sollicitations que nous nous recevons
enfin et c'est ma toute dernière
question et j'ai pour ma part accédé les
deux minutes je vous prie de mon excuser
ma toute dernière question concerne
l'annonce du président de la République
sur le schéma de répartition
des migrants dans notre pays proposés et
déjà instaurer à l'époque par la loi
colon de 2018 qui était indiqué comme
étant une bonne solution selon l'Office
français de l'immigration et
l'intégration par la boîte son Président
je voudrais connaître votre position sur
cette question également monsieur le
ministre je vous donne la parole pour
une à propos introductif et ensuite tous
mes collègues auront évidemment au moins
autant de questions que moi
merci monsieur le Président de la
Commission Mesdames et Messieurs les
parlementaires peuvent être témoins tout
d'abord de réjouir de pouvoir être
devant vous en ce début de mandat pour
pouvoir expliciter effectivement la
feuille de route fixée par madame la
Première ministre au ministère de
l'Intérieur et des Outre-mer je sais que
vous aurez également à cœur vous me
l'avez dit d'additionner les ministres
délégués qui sont auprès de moi
notamment Jean-François carinco en
charge particulièrement de l'outre-mer
Sonia baquet sur la citoyenneté et donc
en partie sur des questions qui relèvent
du séparatisme
et de l'accès à l'intégration et puis
Caroline cailleux avec Christophe BECHU
si j'ose dire puisque dans la
répartition des compétences si le
Ministre en charge et la transition
écologique à tout l'aspect financier et
transition par nature des collectivités
locales le décret de distribution
prévoit que ces deux mystères de
l'Intérieur qui s'occupent des grandes
questions territoriales
institutionnelles j'aurai l'occasion
d'en reparler dans quelques instants
peut-être décliner la feuille de route
sans faire une liste exhaustive puisque
beaucoup de questions seront posées et
que l'intérêt de cette commission est
sans doute de répondre aux questions en
premier des départements
m'attirant peut-être sur trois sujets
rapidement de priorité pour le ministère
de l'Intérieur et donc pour moi-même et
répondre ensuite à vos interrogations
monsieur président d'acquisition des
lois la première priorité que je me fixe
c'est que m'a fixée d'après le ministre
et la réussite de la Coupe du monde de
rugby et des Jeux Olympiques à Paris
mais pas simplement à Paris dans tout
notre pays ce sont des enjeux
extrêmement importants qui prennent
facilement un tiers du temps de mon
agenda puisqu'il s'agit d'occuper pour
septembre 2023 pour la communion de
rugby c'est-à-dire pour demain comme
pour les Jeux Olympiques la question de
la sécurité se pose en la pluriel de ce
mot sécurité puisque le cyber la
sécurité civile l'ordre public la bonne
organisation des flux et la bonne
organisation des événements mais pas
simplement des événements de l'accueil
des délégations des dizaines de millions
de personnes qui vont venir sur notre
sol et dans toutes nos régions jusqu'au
jusqu'au parcours de la flamme avec la
cérémonie qui touchera la fin des Jeux
paralympiques vaut occuper pas
simplement Paris et sa petite couronne
mais toute la France pendant plus de 3
mois dans des conditions exceptionnelles
puisque jamais la coupe les Jeux
Olympiques n'avaient par exemple
organisé une série de d'ouverture en
dehors d'un stade et la série
d'ouverture sur la scène qui va
rassembler plus de 600 000 personnes
sera à la fois un moment de l'imaginant
extrêmement festif et positif pour le
sport en général et pour la France en
particulier mais évidemment quand il y a
autant de flux sur un territoire donné
la lutte contre le terrorisme la lutte
contre la délinquance l'ordre public est
évidemment une condition sinequanone de
sa bonne réussite pour réussir les JO à
la communion de rugby il faut deux
choses des médailles ou des victoires ça
c'est pas l'intérieur qui peut y
contribuer mais la bonne le bon
déroulement en termes de sécurité de ces
de ces enjeux évidemment avec les
policiers légendes les pompiers les
services de renseignement en lien avec
ma collègue Amélie Castera oudea sera
évidemment un moment très important et
une partie de la lot me que vous aurez à
discuter très bientôt après le Sénat va
permettre de pouvoir répondre à ces
exigences le deuxième sujet de priorité
pour moi et la baisse de la délinquance
de voie publique si je devais résumer
monsieur le Président mais vous avez
suivi comme d'autres les débats du
premier quinquennat dans le premier
quinquennat du président de la
République le réarmement de la police
nationale gendarmerie a permis à la fois
de sortir de l'état d'urgence terroriste
je rappelle que lorsque nous sommes
arrivés en responsabilité le pays
connaissait la vague d'attentat
terroriste qui a touché particulièrement
le quinquennat de François Hollande mais
qui avait commencé par la fermera à la
fin du quinquennat Nicolas Sarkozy et le
Parlement avait accordé au gouvernement
des moyens exorbitants du droit commun
par des états d'urgence
particulier et l'une des premières
dispositions était de sortir l'état
d'urgence en passant dans le dur de la
loi dans deux lois antiterroriste
particulièrement mais aussi dans les
moyens que nous mettons au service de
renseignements et notamment au ministère
de l'intérieur des moyens sans précédent
sur les 10000 policiers gendarmes
recrutés dans le quinquennat précédent
4000 ont été à la DGSI et au
renseignement territoriaux que nous
avons restructuré nous avons d'ailleurs
doublé le budget de la DGSI ce qui nous
permet aujourd'hui de considérer la
menace terroriste bien sûr avec acuité
et je veux le redire ici que cette
menace c'est persistante et peut frapper
à tout moment le territoire national
mais au service de renseignement de
d'avoir des jouets 39 attentats
précédents du président de la République
et 8 depuis le début de cette année
attentat souvent pour ne pas dire quasi
exclusivement d'origine islamiste mais
il y a aussi ultra-droite ultra gauche
qui sont concernés parfois la publicité
médiatique en fait on fait des coûts
c'est grâce au lois votées par le
Parlement de renforcement des moyens
notamment technologiques
c'est aussi bien sûr grâce aux moyens
physiques que nous avons mis en place
dans notre pays et si désormais la
menace exogène la menace qui vient de
l'extérieur pour toucher le sol français
par exemple le Bataclan et moins
important de nous avons quand même
un rehaussement des signalements de
terroristes qui viendrait du Levant ou
de l'Afrique subsaharienne 500
signalements qui ont été auprès des
services de renseignement depuis que je
suis ministre de l'Intérieur depuis un
peu plus de deux ans si aucun d'entre
eux n'a été profondément vérifié comme
faisant partie d'une organisation
terroriste qui peut frapper le sol
national il faut rester très attentif à
cette menace exogène la menace
principale vous le savez c'est la menace
endogène la menace de personnes qui se
radicalise à l'intérieur de notre pays
de moins en moins d'ailleurs dans des
cultes de plus en plus sur Internet et
qui peuvent passer dans une forme
d'ubérisation de la violence avec les
derniers attentats que l'on a pu qu'on a
pu connaître bien évidemment
donc si nous pouvons considérer que nous
avons fait un travail très important
contre le terrorisme et qui a montré son
efficacité puisque nous avons réussi
pour l'instant à tenir
la loi ordinaire sans demander des
pouvoirsorbitants du droit commun au
Parlement tout en déjouant 38 attentats
je me souligné que c'est au prix
effectivement de moyens budgétaire très
important prévu par le premier
quinquennat la deuxième si j'ose dire
action que nous menons est une action
très forte contre les violences
intrafamiliales dont la libération de la
parole a révélé pour les femmes mais
aussi pour les enfants énormément de
violence qu'elle soit physique ou
psychologique désormais ces 400 000
procédures si je prends l'année 2021
cette des policiers des gendarmes ça
fait sans doute la délinquance après les
stupéfiants la plus combattue et la plus
suivie par les policiers et les
gendarmes nous avons 150000 policiers
gendarmes qui sont formés désormais
l'intégralité des policiers des
gendarmes qui sortent d'école de police
gend priori sont formés aux violences
intra intrafamilal évidemment encore
beaucoup de travail cette violence
continue à augmenter sur 100%
d'augmentation de la violence physique
dans les statistiques ministère
intérieur 90% de ces violences sont au
sein du couple ce qui montre que
l'augmentation des violences aux
personnes parfois décrié et notamment la
campagne électorale est essentiellement
une violence qui est révélée à
l'intérieur des couples des familles de
France et particulièrement d'ailleurs je
voudrais le souligner un drame se situe
dans les régions les plus touchées
socialement c'est le cas du Nord et du
Pas-de-Calais c'est le cas la
Seine-Saint-Denis c'est le cas de
l'ensemble de nos territoires
ultramarins et je crois que je sais
Monsieur monsieur le Président que
l'ensemble des groupes politiques seront
attentifs à continuer à donner les
moyens à la justice et au histoires de
l'intérieur pour lutter contre ce
véritable fléau que malheureusement nous
accompagnons par une augmentation de
moyens continus
je voudrais désormais regarder les
choses pour
les années qui viennent dans la lutte
contre la délinquance sur la voie
publique les deux années de covid ont
donné une drôle d'impression à nos
concitoyens qui est le même succédé à un
an et demi de manifestations de gilets
jaunes et on peut dire que d'après
précédent n'a pas vraiment connu d'année
pleine à part peut-être la première
année celle de 2017-2018 sans
interférence soit de grands sujets
d'ordre public soit de sujets pandémie
et donc nous retrouvons si j'ose dire
espérons que ce soit le cas pour de
longs mois de longues années le retour à
une vie normale pour les services de
police et de gendarmerie et nous
constatons que les atteintes au bien qui
servent ont baissé pendant le
quinquennat précédent commence à
remonter tout doucement selon le
territoire de la République les
cambriolages les vols de véhicules par
exemple et les attentes aux personnes
notamment les atomes dans la rue la
tente de personnes sur la voie publique
ou dans les transports en commun sont en
continuant augmentation et donc le
deuxième objectif après la réussite des
jeux et la Coupe du monde de rugby c'est
évidemment d'obtenir dans les mois qui
viennent mais si j'ose dire si je me
mets moi-même un objectif dès l'année
2023 pleine la baisse des indicateurs de
délinquance pour des sujets qui touchent
l'entredre public au sens sécurité
publique du terme les violences
physiques dans la rue les violences dans
les transports en commun donc beaucoup
d'agressions sexuelles les cambriolages
et les vols de véhicules pour cela
effectivement une stratégie ou il ne
s'agit pas de demander des moyens
législatifs supplémentaires mais une
meilleure organisation de la police
nationale et de la gendarmerie nationale
je reviendrai bien évidemment une
présence beaucoup plus accrue sur le
terrain des policiers et des gendarmes à
hauteur d'homme et notamment en mettant
à disposition des préfets des unités de
force mobile qui au lieu de faire de
l'ordre public font de la sécurisation
publique cette commune de France vous
l'avez vu ont eu des cet été ces unités
de force mobile et d'ailleurs dans ces
communes de France a commencé par
l'agglomération parisienne on constate
bon mois d'août avec une baisse
importante de la délinquance c'est aussi
le cas à Marseille où j'étais hier on a
constaté 8% de base de la délinquance
dans les transports en commun par
exemple et donc les moyens en effectif
supplémentaire soit ceux accordés dans
la dernière année budgétaire merci au
parlementaire de la majorité de l'avoir
voté soit se demander à la loopy et dès
cette année par les effectifs évoqués
cette présence plus forte de la police
nationale de gendarmerie surtout à pied
surtout dans les lieux où il y a de la
délinquance de voie publique devrait
nous permettre de pouvoir faire baisser
cette délinquance de voie publique j'y
reviendrai troisième sujet c'est
évidemment un sujet de réchauffement
climatique et du travail que fait le
ministère de l'Intérieur dans la
transition écologique souhaitée par le
Président de la République et notamment
vous l'avez vu cet été le réchauffement
climatique touche profondément
l'appareil de sécurité civile que les
Français constatent et non vu ces
mégafeux ces mégafeux qui touchent tout
le contour méditerranéen et qui
désormais bien sûr touche non seulement
les régions les plus touchées
habituellement je pense en France à la
Corse ou à la région provençale-côte
d'Azur qui d'habitude connaît les feux
les plus importants mais cette année
particulièrement l'Aquitaine et puis
sans faire la météo remonter au nord de
la Loire où nous avons désormais eu des
feux de 1500 ou 2000 hectares dans le
Maine-et-Loire dans le Finistère
c'est-à-dire des régions qui n'ont
jamais été touchées par des feux de
forêt et qui aujourd'hui répondent à un
impératif de réchauffement climatique le
réchauffement climatique n'est pas
toujours la cause de ces feux mais c'est
souvent la condition du fait que ces
feux se propagent puisque si 9 choses
sur 10 sont d'origine humaine soit
volontairement soit involontairement
évidemment il faut que le biotope c'est
j'ose dire soit prêt à accueillir ces
feux pour se propager il y a tout un
sujet de transition écologique chez
Christophe Béchu notamment
d'organisations de nos forêts même si je
veux remarquer ici que parmi les 100%
des feux qu'il y a eu cet été seulement
10% touché des forêts publics et 90% des
forêts privés donc il s'agit vous en
parlerai avec le ministre la transition
écologique de l'entretien des forêts
privés essentiellement mais je veux ici
souligner le fait que l'hydrométrie a
été jusqu'à moins de 10% en Gironde par
exemple et qui a permis de créer une
propagation malheureusement très
importante des feux que nous avons
constaté et des moyens humains je pense
bien sûr aux pompiers aux
sapeurs-pompiers qui soient volontaires
professionnels des moyens militaires
puisque nous avons des fourmisques qui
dépend du ministère de l'intérieur ou
des moyens aériens qui mériteraient
d'être vu de façon différente dans leur
stratégie et plus importante dans leur
moyen et donc je veux dire à monsieur le
président de la commission des lois et à
vous tous que nous réfléchissons en ce
moment même non seulement à la saison de
feu de l'année prochaine attention la
saison de feu qu'il faut arriver en même
temps que les Jeux Olympiques ce qui
forcerait bien sûr nos forces de l'ordre
et le ministère d'intérieur à se déplier
sur plusieurs
opérations de sécurité civile en même
temps cette résilience est très très
importante et puis évidemment de
réfléchir aussi aux attentes à
l'environnement de plus en plus
nombreuses de la création de la
gendarmerie verte que j'ai eu l'occasion
d'évoquer qui fait clairement partie de
ma feuille de route également réussite
la Coupe du monde de rugby des Jeux
Olympiques baisse de la délinquance de
voie publique la sécurité civile à
l'heure du réchauffement climatique
voici les trois grands domaines sur
lesquels je vais particulièrement me
déployer ainsi que sa mise en intérieur
se rajoute à cela monsieur le Président
des questions institutionnelles qui sont
propres effectivement à mon décret
d'attribution des questions qui sont
co-part partagées avec d'autres
politiques publiques mais qui verront
bientôt le jour à l'Assemblée Sénat
d'abord par un débat ensuite par un
texte de loi vous l'avez dit le sujet
autour de l'immigration on en reparlera
on en reparlera j'imagine dans les dans
les questions je n'aurais pas besoin de
dire sur sur ce point deuxième sujet
très important institutionnellement
c'est le travail que nous faisons autour
de la collectivité de Corse puisque au
départ pour plus d'un an de discussion
institutionnelle avec l'ensemble des
élus de l'île de beauté de la
Nouvelle-Calédonie
puisque le troisième référendum qui a
définitivement mis la France en lien
avec évidemment le travail qui avait
fait deux gouvernements précédents mais
en lien avec la Calédonie et le vote
décalé de lien faut qu'il faut créer
désormais un nouvel espoir une nouvelle
institution d'avenir pour Lille de
Nouvelle-Calédonie et nous avons autant
sur la liste électorale que sur le
régime institutionnel a travaillé et
sans doute des modifications
constitutionnelles à organiser c'est
aussi évidemment le cas d'autres
territoires ultramarins qui réclament
des évolutions statutaires c'est aussi
le cas du Conseil Territorial dont le
président de la République souhaite vous
le savez la mise en place durant ce
mandat la fusion des conseillers
départementaux et des conseillers
régionaux par l'élection c'est aussi de
le cas de la métropole du Grand Paris
ainsi que celle du Grand Marseille
c'est donc des sujets institutionnels
très forts dont j'aurai l'occasion
monsieur le Président sans doute soit
par les travaux Parlement en réaction
soit par vos propres demandes d'audition
de détailler le contenu si les
commissaires ne veulent pas le souligner
désormais pour répondre et pour en
terminer donc pour pas prendre trop de
temps des questions on est posé si j'ai
bien noté 4 séries de questions vous
demandez à quoi finalement à quoi
serviront les effectifs les 8500 prévus
dans la loi d'orientation et de
programmation du ministère de
l'Intérieur si elle est votée bien
évidemment par le par le Parlement sur
les 8500 créations d'effectifs je peux
vous donner la ventilation année par
année monsieur le Président et
thématique par thématique je voudrais
peut-être me concentrer sur les deux
premières années puisque si je me donne
comme objectif que la baisse de la
délinquance de voie publique est
organisations de la Coupe du monde de
rugby et des JO se passent dans des
bonnes conditions les années 2023 à 2024
sont évidemment extrêmement importants
pour obtenir ces sujets alors police et
gendarmerie 52 créations 52% de création
dans la police nationale 48% de création
dans la gendarmerie nationale pour la
police c'est la création des quatre CRS
8 que j'ai évoqués c'est à dire des
compagnies de républicaine de sécurité
qu'on pourrait appeler mobile comme
celle que nous avons mis en place
désormais dans les Yvelines et qui
interviennent notamment sur les
questions dans le public et qui
interviennent désormais extrêmement
rapidement dont une sera installée à
Marseille l'autre à Chassieu dans le
Rhône la troisième à Nantes dans la
Loire-Atlantique la quatrième à
Montauban pour la région
Occitanie ça veut dire que la création
des effectifs de Cérès pour faire quatre
CRS c'est 200 pour la crs8 200 effectif
de CRS par unité et nous prévoyons 600
créations d'effectifs dès 2023 et 200024
c'est à dire que les quatre CRS seraient
créé dès les deux premières années du
mandat pour les augmentations
d'effectifs de police dans les
commissariats de sécurité publique qui
ont été vous le savez la priorité des
deux dernières années budgétaires que
j'ai pu diriger en prévoyons aussi 104
créations de ce poste de policiers
supplémentaire hormis la préfecture de
police en premier transport en commun
j'y reviendrai dont 507 dès la première
année et 97 dès la seconde année c'est à
dire que l'intégralité des augmentations
d'effectives de police dans les
commissariats seraient créé des deux
premières années de mandat et
singulièrement dans la première nous
allons mettre particulièrement l'accent
sur les transports en commun et
notamment dans la région parisienne de
50% des actes délinquance dans les
transports en commun a lieu à Paris et
dans la petite couronne et notamment
énormément d'agressions envers les
femmes et donc une direction unique de
la police et de la gendarmerie sur les
transports en commun sera créé et des
effectifs extrêmement renforcés dans les
grandes agglomérations de France 450 en
tout dont les deux tiers 200 et 122 les
deux premières années budgétaires la
préfecture de police verra elle
l'arrivée de 1000 policiers
supplémentaires
comblant ainsi la difficulté nous avons
à Paris avec le nouveau préfet de police
constater effectivement
l'importance d'une saturation sans doute
de l'espace public dans certains
quartiers de la capitale songez que dans
le nord de Paris il y a eu plus de
violences urbaines qu'en
Seine-Saint-Denis l'été dernier et que
ça pose donc des questions de changement
sociologiques de la de la ville de Paris
et sans doute aussi de d'urbanisme mais
de réponse policières il y a eu
évidemment à attirer des conséquences
des des mois précédents nous allons
faire une transformation extrêmement
importante puisque vous ne verrez plus
de policiers aux frontières dans les
aubettes des aéroports mais des
personnels civils du ministère de
l'Intérieur et donc nous pourrons grâce
à une transformation forte récupérer des
policiers formés en uniforme armé pour
faire autre chose que le contrôle des
passeports ou des pièces d'identité ça
cela arrive dès l'année prochaine avec
la création des effectifs que nous
proposons c'est une réforme réforme très
importante qui permet de regagner des
patrouilles et de la présence de voie
publique et de pouvoir encore
professionnaliser l'accueil dans nos
aéroports nous allons aussi créer des
assistants d'enquêtes des formes de
greffier de police qui sont prévus dans
la dans la transmis l'idée c'est que le
magistrat le juge du siège par exemple
il a un greffier qui l'aide qui tape à
l'ordinateur qui appelle l'avocat qui
discute avec lui puis le magistrat se
concentre sur les actes propres
d'enquêtes aujourd'hui le policier
gendarme lui il fait l'intégralité de la
démarche il est le policier qui est à la
fois accueille le la personne qui a été
mis en garde à vue qui appelle son
avocat qui appelle le médecin qui livre
le repas bref il y a des actions
administratives qui ne relèvent pas la
formation des officiers de police
judiciaire ces assistants d'enquêtes
dont nous discutons évidemment
distributions pour qu'une grande partie
d'entre eux soit à PJ vient du personnel
administratif technique et scientifique
du ministère de l'intérieur elle
permettra évidemment de donner aussi un
une méritocratie à ces personnels
extrêmement courageux et puis il y a une
agence unique du numérique au ministère
de l'Intérieur la moitié des 15
milliards d'euros demandés par la lot
Miss c'est le cyber et le numérique nous
y reviendrons très certainement et cette
agence unique qui vient fusionner
plusieurs directions du ministère de
l'Intérieur
50 emplois dès 2023 et 50 de 2024 donc
pour résumer ces 1900 dans la police en
2023 et 1130 dans la police en 2024 pour
la gendarmerie nous créons les 7
escadron de gendarmerie mobile dans les
11 ufm c'est 7 escadron de gendarmerie
mobile 4 unités de CRS c'est vers 840
gendarmes mobiles dont 420 420 sont
créés les deux premières années pour que
les 11 escadrons de gendarmerie mobile
SRS soient prêts pour les Jeux
Olympiques bien évidemment donc
l'intégralité des unités de force mobile
nous reprenons les garde statiques de la
préfecture de police il y a 7 unités de
force mobiles qui gardent les Lisée Bovo
un certain nombre d'ambassades ça c'est
des unités de force mobile qui nous
coûte cher parce qu'ils viennent de
province pour tenir ces lieux parisiens
et qui pour autant sont mal utilisés
puisque leur travail c'est faire de
l'ordre public et pas de la gare de
statique et donc au 11 escadron de
gendarmerie de ces risques de Créon nous
libérons 7 unités supplémentaires ce qui
fait 18 unités de force mobile pour les
Jeux Olympiques pour que les unités de
France face à travailler de force mobile
et que les gardes de statiques de la PP
notamment la Garde Républicaine puisse
être au rendez-vous de la tenue de ces
de ces de ces sites importants et
sensibles à Paris 200 brigades de
gendarmerie seront créés je lancerai la
semaine prochaine dans le Cher le début
de discussion entre les élus locaux et
nationaux et les préfets et la direction
générale la gendarmerie pour février
prochain nous aurons la carte des 200
brigades on peut imaginer que on pourra
créer entre deux et trois brigades par
département à l'exception des
départements extrêmement urbains bien
évidemment mais c'est à peu près les les
le calcul il y aura donc 2144 gendarmes
recrutaient spécifiquement pour les
brigades territoriales que nous venons
d'annoncer 312 en 2023 378 en 2024 nous
avons en police en gendarmerie de
recrutement de 350 formateurs pour
pouvoir accompagner un certain nombre
d'évolution et de formation continue de
la police nationale et de la gendarmerie
et puis j'ai évoqué la gendarmerie verte
et l'agence numérique par ailleurs ce
qui fait que pour la gendarmerie c'est
1950 créations de postes en 2023 et 1045
en 2024 je pense que je peux pas être
plus difficile mais je peux vous laisser
le tableau monsieur le Président si vous
le souhaitez les escadron de gendarmerie
gendarmerie mobile supplémentaire seront
créés à Melun à Hyères à jouer les tours
à Villeneuve-d'Ascq à Dijon à Thionville
et à Lodève donc ils sont évidemment
partis tous sur le territoire national
j'ai évidemment pensé à Monsieur
bernalicis en lui envoyant des gendarmes
mobiles je voudrais poser d'autres
réponses peut-être à votre question sur
les refus d'obtempérer moi je veux
m'associer avec vous monsieur le
monsieur le Président
renverse ce policier du Nord qui
effectivement a dans la nuit était entre
la la vie et la mort et qui à ma
connaissance son pronostic vital n'est
plus engagé mais on ne sait pas encore
si il aura des séquelles et sans puisque
c'est devenu public sans les sans les
sans le sang froid de ses collègues on
peut retrouver d'ailleurs dans le
véhicule une grande quantité de drogue
donc le refus de tempéré n'est pas
toujours le fait de personnes qui
seraient un peu distrait au volant je
voudrais quand même le souligner parce
que parfois c'est le débat public que
j'entends c'est au fait de tempérer ils
ont augmenté de 13 % depuis 2016 en 2021
il y en a eu 27609 quand ils étaient
24409 en 2016 et je veux dire que depuis
le 1er janvier 41 blessés grave dans les
rangs de la police et de la gendarmerie
depuis le 1er janvier sur les refusent
de tempérer malheureusement si j'ose
dire on ne s'attarde pas autant sur
chaque en policier gendarme gravement
blessé parce que un véhicule ne s'arrête
pas monsieur le Président comme je vous
doutais que le sujet était d'actualité
je me suis permis de sortir la fiche de
renseignement que j'ai tous les matins
sur mon bureau sur les événements de la
nuit il n'y a eu rien que cette nuit 5
refuses de tempérés graves envers les
policiers légendes le relais que kervons
désolé pour les pour les pour les pour
les Bretons
usage des armes par les vous opérer d'un
véhicule signalé voler tire en direction
du pneu véhicule en fuite à Toulouse à
20h30 refuse d'opérer par véhicule qui
s'accidenté tout seul dans un virage le
conducteur est blessé à Nantes et refuse
de tempéré par un véhicule qui percute
un autre véhicule auteur interpellé
l'occupant était âgé de 70 ans dans le
véhicule qui était lui stationné
normalement elle est aujourd'hui au
centre hospitalier de Nantes à Anzin on
vient de parler de ce pauvre policier et
à Étampes où le refus de repérer du
véhicule termine sa course dans un arbre
conducteur est blessé et évidemment
était si j'ose dire évidemment sous
l'empreinte alcoolique 5 refusent de
tempérer grave rien que cette nuit je
suis prêt à parier puisque c'est à peu
près les mêmes fiches chaque jour sur
mon bureau que ce sera la même chose
demain et après-demain donc
effectivement monsieur le Président
s'est refait vous verrez toutes les
demi-heure touche d'ailleurs autant les
zones police que gendarmerie pour autant
puisque la question sera sans doute
posée les tirs des policiers des
gendarmes ne sont pas
particulièrement en augmentation 137 en
2016 202 en 2017 170 en 2018 147 en 2019
153 en 2020 donc je rappelle que c'était
une année covid ou c'était censé avoir
moins de véhicule sur la route 157 en
2021 si je compare avec les ADN de 2018
et 2017 il tire même en proportion moins
que dans les années non une année covid
mais il y a plus de refus d'obtempérer
je veux redire que la consigne que
j'assume totalement la direction
générale de la police nationale la
direction générale la gendarmerie
nationale c'est que il est évident que
qu'il s'agisse de rodéo urbain ou de
refus d'obtempérer il est possible de
poursuivre le véhicule et les mêmes du
devoir des policiers du gendarmes de le
faire et de s'arrêter lorsqu'ils sont en
véhicule lorsque il considère que les
choses deviennent dangereux pour
eux-mêmes ou pour les personnes qui
viennent à traverser ou à circuler et
qui pourraient subir la course-poursuite
ou la chasse et le deuxième point c'est
qu'effectivement dans des conditions
encadrées par le de déontologie les
refus d'obtempérer lorsque le véhicule
se transforme en arme contre le
policiers ou le gendarme ils sont
autorisés à tirer j'attire l'attention
qu'à chaque fois que la policier ou
qu'un gendarme tire l'inspection
générale de la police nationale de la
gendarmerie nationale ouvrent une
enquête il est extrêmement
automatique
je ne sais pas je n'ai pas le
pourcentage mais manifestement je n'ai
pas d'histoire où le policier de
gendarme n'est pas mis lui-même en garde
à vue ou présenter devant un magistrat
dont on à chaque fois il est donc
évidemment procédé à une enquête sur
chacune des autorisations de de tir des
policiers des gendarmes dont je veux ici
redire mon entier soutien devant leur
métier difficile et me trouver à la fois
si ce n'est en colère au moins chagriner
que tous les élus de la République ne
portent pas le même soutien aux
policiers et aux gendarmes je voudrais
terminer pour peut-être évoquer la
question des des migration
et notamment les migrations de travail
que vous avez évoqué monsieur le
Président il est évident que ce débat
est un débat complexe et qu'il touche
l'ensemble du champ ministériel je le
dis en citant l’idée du stop puisque je
travaille particulièrement avec lui sur
ce sujet moi je pense monsieur le
Président que nous avons à améliorer
bien sûr notre politique d'immigration
envers les délinquants étrangers avec
plus de fermeté je me suis exprimé
publiquement sur ce propos mais aussi de
meilleur intégration des personnes qui
travaillent sur le sol de la République
et qui sont soumis soit une absurdité
administrative de la part du
fonctionnement administratif de du
ministère de l'Intérieur et donc je
l'assume pleinement pour améliorer très
largement ce processus des travaux ont
été faits il y a moins de fil
d'étrangers si je veux dire j'aurais
préfecture mais parfois ces fils sont
numériques ou parfois elles existent
encore et elles sont inacceptables du
point de vue de l'intégration de des
personnes qui veulent vivre sur notre
sol mais aussi de du peu de cas que font
certains employeurs des personnels
immigrés qu'ils recrutent et si une
grande immense majorité j'imagine
d'employeurs respectent le code du
travail et regarde les choses avec
intérêt j'ai entendu le Medef qui paraît
campagne présidentielle se souhaitait
davantage d'immigration de travail
le débat ne va partir pas et la partie
évidemment à la première ministre est au
Parlement de fixer des évolutions
législatives il y a des choses qui me
choquent personnellement en tant que
ministre de l'intérieur mais même en
tant que citoyen je trouve pas normal
que seul L'employeur peut demander la
régularisation de la personne qui
travaille pour lui comme si
l'employé lui-même ne pouvait pas faire
cette demande de régularisation je
crains malheureusement qu'une pression
trop forte sur ce que de temps on
pourrait appeler l'armée de réserve fait
que on accepte des horaires décalés on
fasse beaucoup de harcèlement sur
certains salariés et je pense que dans
les conflits sociaux qu'on connu un
certain nombre de travailleurs notamment
sans papiers ils ont toujours trouvé le
ministre de l'Intérieur auprès d'eux je
madame poulain par exemple qui a
travaillé auprès de la CGT et travailler
sur ses combats a été particulièrement
je crois écouté par le ministère de et
contribuer à ces régularisation je
trouve par exemple anormal que les cours
de français que doivent prendre les
étrangers qui travaillent sur le sol
national doivent se faire pendant les
heures de travail alors que pendant ces
heures de travail là l'employeur ne
laisse pas aller vers ses cours de
français et donc il y a une sorte de de
débat un peu malsains entre le travail
et l'intégration il faut absolument que
nous changeons ça et je trouve en effet
normal monsieur le Président que des
personnes qui ont un contrat de travail
voient leur renouvellement de titre de
séjour arrivés qui ne pose pas premier à
la République parfois perdre leur
contrat de travail par mauvaise
organisation des services du ministère
de l'Intérieur vous aurez constaté
d'ailleurs que pour la première fois
dans un budget de présentera mise à
l'intérieur depuis plus de 20 ans il y a
340 effectifs de plus dans les
préfectures depuis je suis intérieur on
a stoppé la chute des baisses des ETP
dans les préfectures désormais il
remonte à 340 peut-être que ce n'est pas
encore assez mais en tout cas ils sont
là pour être au rendez-vous évidemment
du service public moi je m'en orgueille
de cet arbitrage rendu personnellement
par la par la première ministre à ma
demande sa première fois d'ailleurs
qu'on va recréer des sous-préfectures on
aura l'occasion d'en reparler très
certainement enfin je voudrais attirer
l'attention de quelques membres de la
commission des lois sur les trappes à
irrégularisation que nous créons
nous-même par nos propres législations
pour créer une auto-entreprise on n'a
pas besoin de montrer qu'on a des
papiers et il y a un système de
fonctionnement capitaliste que vous avez
parfois évoqué dans d'autres scénacles
qui fait qu'on embauche des gens en
auto-entrepreneur il paye des impôts
voir des cotisations sans en bénéficier
parce qu'ils sont irréguliers et après
ils viennent dans les préfectures pour
demander leur régularisation ils ne sont
pas régularisables il faut absolument
qu'avec Bercy nous mettion fin à cette à
cette possibilité pour qu'on puisse pas
bien évidemment ça paraît le bon sens de
créer une entreprise lorsqu'on n'est pas
régulièrement sur le territoire national
voilà en quelques mots monsieur le
monsieur le Président je pense avoir
répondu à vos propos introductifs
merci Monsieur le Ministre j'ai donné la
parole aux différents reprend dans des
groupes avant de donner la parole
différent députés madame Marie guévenou
pour le groupe Renaissance
d'abord laissez-moi vous dire au nom du
groupe Renaissance toute la solidarité
et ne veut de rétablissement aux
policiers qui a été victime de ce refus
d'obtempérer donc vous parliez tout à
l'heure monsieur le ministre et monsieur
le Président
votre action sur le quinquennat
précédent a été marqué par une
augmentation forte des moyens que ce
soit aussi bien les moyens informatiques
tablette véhicules réfection des
commissariats des casernes et puis aussi
par une augmentation des effectifs des
forces de l'ordre or vous l'avez dit
tout à l'heure monsieur le ministre nous
aurons dans les années à venir deux
événements majeurs les Jeux Olympiques
et la Coupe du monde de rugby qui vont
nécessiter
l'organisation le déploiement de force
de l'ordre en très grand nombre pour que
ces événements soient parfaitement
réussi et ici évidemment tout le monde
le comprend
moi j'aimerais vous interroger sur deux
points à ce sujet le premier c'est
est-ce que vous nous en dire un peu plus
sur le déploiement que vous envisagez
pour la réussite de ces deux événements
et puis le second c'est que au fond et
vous l'avez dit
les enjeux de sécurité dans certains
départements dans certains territoires
et ben ils sont toujours là et comment
vous envisagez de déployer ses effectifs
dans ces départements qui font face à
des enjeux de sécurité importants c'est
la député de l'Essonne mais il y a pas
que l'Essonne qui concerné par ces
problématiques et aussi l'Île-de-France
et puis provenant d'autres territoires
de Provence province donc comment vous
envisagez cette cette répartition des
effectifs pour maintenir l'effort qui
avait été le vôtre pendant 5 ans
seconde partie de mes questions portera
sur la mission d'information dont tu as
parlé le président de la commission
la locmi qui sera examinée par le Sénat
contient dans c'est déjà des articles
sur l'investigation on sait que c'est
une un domaine qui est en crise comment
ça s'articule avec les discussions que
vous menez sur la réforme merci Monsieur
ministre merci Monsieur romain Aubry
pour le groupe rassemblement national
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre très heureux d'être à la place
qui est la mienne aujourd'hui avant afin
d'avoir une liberté de parole et de
pouvoir exprimer et rétablir les vérités
venant directement du terrain car de
nouveau véhicules la peinture sur les
murs c'est bien c'est même très bien
pour les conditions de travail dans nos
forces de l'ordre mais c'est n'est pas
ce qui va assurer davantage la sécurité
des Français entre un laxisme judiciaire
vous auriez dû mettre un uniforme
monsieur et vous en aurez parlé
autrement entre un laxisme judiciaire ou
la culture de l'excuse est prédominante
et votre incapacité à expulser les
clandestins ainsi que les délinquants et
criminés à l'étranger ce sont nos
comptes patriotes qui chaque jour sont
agressés voler violet ou tués au nom du
vivre ensemble prenez par ceux qui ne
vivent pas avec
ce sont aussi nos forces de l'ordre dans
toutes leurs composantes qui trinquent
de par votre incapacité à assurer
l'ordre et à faire appliquer la loi il
subisse chaque jour de Lourdes
agressions tentatives de meurtre ou même
meurtre parfois l'épuisement est extrême
et le moral est en berne dans les rangs
le sentiment de faire un travail
inefficace sous la pression parfois
d'une hiérarchie qui ne voit que par la
politique du chiffre est omniprésent il
y a 15 ans avec Michel et lyon-marie il
fallait gonfler les chiffres sur les
passages d'individus aux fichiers il y a
10 ans avec Manuel Valls les tentatives
de cambriolage devaient se transformer
en simple dégradations et avec vous
monsieur le ministre on effectue des
simples contrôles routiers et on les
classe en lutte contre les routes des
motorisées les professionnels de la
sécurité publique sont dans l'action
tandis que vous n'êtes que dans
l'agitation et dans la réaction ma
première question la voici Monsieur le
Ministre quelle mesure forte allez vous
prendre pour assurer véritablement la
sécurité des Français la seconde
quand allez-vous prendre la mesure de
l'épuisement des forces de l'ordre et
agir pour endiguer la vague de suicide
qui dessime les rangs les questions que
je vous pose ce ne sont que
quelques-unes des questions que je me
suis posé durant ces 15 dernières années
que ce soit en simple citoyen ou en tant
que membre des forces de l'ordre mais
compter sur moi pour vous demander très
régulièrement des comptes durant cette
législature je vous remercie merci
pour le groupe la France insoumise merci
monsieur le Président bonjour à toutes
et à tous
avant tout au nom de notre groupe nous
tenons bien sûr à nous associer au
soutien
par rapport aux policiers blessés comme
à tous ceux qui sont blessés dans
l'exercice de leur fonction monsieur le
ministre nous vous alertons sur la pente
glissante que votre gouvernement ne
cesse d'emprunter depuis des années
celle qui vise à repeindre en ennemi de
la République le moindre des adversaires
politiques nous avons pris acte de votre
décision d'expulser l'imami qsen les
propos que vous lui prolongez ne pouvez
pas vous gêner lorsque vous dignez avec
lui des années plus tôt dans le but de
conquérir la mairie de Tourcoing selon
les commentateurs juridiques le droit au
respect de la vie familiale de l'imam né
en France ayant des enfants français n'a
pas été respecté c'est le retour de la
double peine l'affaire reste pendant le
tribunal administratif qui sanctionnera
le cas échéant la violation de la
Convention européenne des droits de
l'homme votre chat sous ennemi de la
République ne s'arrête pas là nous avons
appris que le préfet de la Vienne
demande à la ville de Poitiers de
retirer son soutien financier à un
événement organisé par alternatiba il
s'agissait pourtant d'un atelier de
formation sur la désobéissance civile
une activité par nature non-violente
dans le cadre de la lutte contre le
réchauffement climatique mais il affirme
que cette association a rompu son
engagement républicain cette convention
absconses introduite par votre loi sur
le séparatisme islamiste nous vous
alertions dans l'hémicycle il y a plus
d'un an sur les risques
instrumentalisation de ce type de
dispositif les associations
environnantes environnementalistes en
paix le prix aujourd'hui comme à
l'époque où l'état d'urgence permettait
d'assigner à résidence des militants
écologistes à l'occasion de la cop21
monsieur le ministre alternatiba
touchera-t-elle la subvention pour son
action citoyenne non-violente portant
sur un sujet que le Président de la
République considère lui-même comme le
combat du siècle
merci monsieur Éric Ciotti pour le
couple les républicains merci monsieur
le Président Monsieur le Ministre
quelque part vous êtes passé aux aveux
dans votre déclaration liminaire puisque
vous avez reconnu une augmentation des
atteintes au bien et une très forte
augmentation des atteintes aux personnes
c'est ce que nous disons c'est ce que
vous avez toujours nié à la veille de
l'élection présidentielle les chiffres
sont là 45% d'augmentation donc cette
Love Me elle est bienvenu elle est
bienvenu nous l'attendions nous
l'attendions depuis 6 ans nous la
réclamions
donc le problème n'est pas ce qu'elle
contient le contenu de cette loi y
compris sur son volet pour l'outre-mer
et pour Mayotte ou la situation se
dégrade et je pense notamment la
modification du droit du sol vont dans
le bon sens
le problème c'est plutôt ce que ne
contient pas cette Love Me pas de voler
judiciaire ou presque pas de peine
plancher c'est l'occasion de dire mon
soutien aux policiers dans un bien sûr
comme l'ont fait plusieurs collègues
nous réclamons et le groupe républicain
avait porté un texte dans l'hémicycle
des peines plancher contre ceux qui
portent atteinte ou qui autre âge nos
forces de l'ordre c'est une priorité pas
de double peine pour les délinquants
étrangers vous avez pourtant Monsieur le
Ministre vous-même et établit la vérité
des chiffres enfin là aussi sur le lien
direct entre délinquance et immigration
et pas de voler monsieur le ministre sur
l'immigration c'est tout à fait étonnant
voler a été enlevé vous avez parlé des
liens directs entre immigration et
délinquance il y a aucun volet matériel
pour pour améliorer les conditions
d'expulsion aucun volet matériel pour
augmenter le nombre de places en centre
de attention nous y voyons dès lacunes
très forte donc bien entendu ce texte va
dans le bon sens mais pourquoi c'est
lacunes pourquoi rien sur le volet pénal
on aurait aimé une loi d'orientation
globale sécuritaire et justice la
réponse aurait été plus pertinente et
pourquoi cette absence sur le volet
migratoire merci Madame Elodie Jacky
Laforge pour le groupe démocrate en
visio merci merci bonjour à tous merci
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
monsieur le ministre bien évidemment au
nom de mon groupe aussi nous adressons
tout notre soutien aux politiques a été
blessé mais de façon générale à
l'ensemble de nos forces de l'ordre vous
avez présenté monsieur le ministre en
conseil des ministres donc le 7
septembre dernier la prochaine loi
d'orientation et de programmation du
ministère de l'intérieur avec un budget
de près de 15 milliards d'euros donc ce
projet de loi est traduit la volonté de
l'exécutif de moderniser le ministère et
ses services de recruter des policiers
et des gendarmes ça a été indiqué
identifié les prochains défis qu'ils
soient sécuritaire numérique ou
environnementaux vous en avez parlé tout
en restant bien évidemment dans le
spectre du ministère de l'Intérieur le
groupe démocrates salut le projet et qui
porte sur l'amélioration des moyens
spécifiques pour gérer les compétences
du ministère
financiers humains matériels ou
juridique au nom de mon groupe je
souhaiterais porter mon intervention sur
un volet spécifique que vous avez évoqué
qui concerne la sécurité civile et plus
particulièrement les moyens qui sont
alloués aux pompiers car face à la
gestion de crise de la sécurité civile
il est nécessaire de mettre tous les
moyens vous en avez parlé financier
humain matériel juridique vous l'avez
également dit de nombreux départements
ont été touchés par les incendies et des
nouveaux départements si je puis dire
qu'ils n'étaient pas confrontés
précédemment à des incendies ou à des ou
à des méga feu et c'est grâce au travail
avec les collectivités au courage aussi
nos soldats du feu que ces combats
contre le feu ont pu être maîtrisé nous
avons obtenu aussi l'aide européenne via
le dispositif rescue afin de multiplier
diversité les appareils utilisés vous
avez parlé du réchauffement climatique
et du biotope aussi sur lequel il se il
se situait
ma question elle porte
spécifiquement excusez-moi sur des
éléments qui peuvent
concerner le monde le montant vraiment
de la modernisation spécifiquement sur
l'aviation de la sécurité civile
avez-vous des éléments océan aux données
sur l'utilisation éventuelle des drones
pour détecter et anticiper
ses feux c'est des parts de feu il y a
un sujet aussi sur la prévention je suis
désolé
passé votre temps et que je divise
scrupuleusement
la deuxième question je vous remercie
monsieur le Président merci à vous
madame Cécile est un meilleur pour le
groupe socialiste merci monsieur le
président
est-ce que j'ai pu entendre il y a des
dispositions de procédure pénal qui
d'ailleurs poseront des questions et
peut-être faut-il aussi limiter nos
efforts sur cette procédure pénale parce
que a changé en permanence le code les
magistrats perdent vraiment en
efficacité et nous en lisibilité ça
c'est une observation luminaire
simplement j'ai une question de fond sur
la loop mi par rapport à la création de
ces directions uniques de la police
nationale
donc vous avez lancé l'expérimentation
en janvier 2022 et qui en fait
apparaissent dans la loopmie comme
généralisée en janvier 2023 ce qui pose
un problème sur lequel peut-être vous
pourrez nous donner des explications le
principe de l'expérimentation on le sait
c'est souvent ce qu'on n'ose pas faire
d'emblée et on lance une expérimentation
mais de là à la généraliser avant même
que le bilan en soit dressé moi me pose
problème vraiment me pose problème parce
que est-ce que je vote une
expérimentation si je sais que son
appréciation et son bilan ne sera pas
partagé avant de décider de se générer
réalisation donc ça c'est la première
question et c'est pas qu'une question de
forme c'est une question de fond parce
que pour en avoir parlé avec les acteurs
locaux ceux-ci sont très réservés par
rapport aux incidents sur la police sur
les officiers de police judiciaire et en
particulier sur l'indépendance de la
justice par rapport à la police et de
l'indépendance du procureur par rapport
à
par rapport à un préfet et à une
Direction Départementale certes le
procureur s'est écrit dans la loi le
procureur et le préfet décide ensemble
mais ce qui ressort des informations que
moi j'ai reçu c'est que c'est
généralement pas le procureur c'est le
préfet qui décide voilà la question que
je voulais vous poser merci Monsieur
Didier Lemaire pour le groupe horizon
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre je vous remercie pour la clarté
de votre présentation mes collègues et
moi-même membres du groupe horizon
sommes heureux de pouvoir travailler
avec vous sur tous les grands chantiers
qui attendent votre ministère j'ai
plusieurs questions à vous poser la
première concerne le possible européen
de la sécurité civile à Nîmes dans la
conjoncture actuelle face à
l'intensification des crises leur
multiplication et leur caractère
transfrontaliers il est indispensable
que les pays européens soient en mesure
de pouvoir porter assistance à leurs
voisins ou recevoir assistance de leur
part si besoin les incendies de ces
derniers mois ont permis de montrer le
volontarisme et la compétence de notre
de notre pays en la matière en matière
de sécurité civile
ce mécanisme doit être développé pour
parvenir d'une part à une véritable
coopération européenne et d'autre part à
une anticipation et une programmation
maximum dans la lutte contre les
incendies la flotte d'avion est un outil
efficace dès lors pouvez-vous nous
indiquer si vous envisagez de
transformer la base aérienne de Nîmes
garons en pôle européen de sécurité
civile si oui ou en sont les discussions
au niveau européen et à quelle échéance
cela est-il envisagé
l'autre sujet sur lequel je souhaite
vous interroger n'a pas de corrélation
avec celui des incendies mais est
malheureusement un autre sujet brûlant
l'actualité pardon nous rappelle de
façon quasi quotidienne que les
violences intra familiales existent en
France je salue les dispositions de la
loompi qui vont permettre entre autres
le déploiement de 2000 enquêteurs
spécialisés supplémentaires la formation
de 90 000 policiers gendarmes ainsi que
tous les élèves policiers gendarmes le
meilleur accueil des victimes et la
possibilité de recueillir la plainte à
distance sont d'autant d'avancer qui
doivent être salués
à ce sujet pourriez-vous nous indiquer
si l'application ma sécurité mise en
place depuis le printemps de cette année
est un outil dont se saisisse les
personnes qui luttent les violences
conjugales pouvez-vous d'ores et déjà
nous indiquer quand est-ce que la
fonctionnalité permettant de déposer
plainte en ligne sera mise en place
effectivement enfin envisagez-vous de
mener une campagne de publicité
particulière dans notre pays pour la
promouvoir auprès de toutes et de merci
je vous remercie madame pour le groupe
écologiste
merci bonjour monsieur le Président
bonjour monsieur le ministre
on est aujourd'hui en audition avec vous
parce qu'on doit s'interroger sur les
réformes de la police dans les temps à
venir et j'ai envie de vous poser la
question une réforme ok mais pour quel
projet qu'est-ce qu'on veut mettre au
service de la population française et
comment on restaure ce que la
Constitution nous devrait devrait tous
et toutes nous obliger à honorer à
savoir notre slogan liberté égalité
fraternité et pour ça faut une volonté
politique et je ne suis pas sûr de la
déceler dans les chiffres que vous venez
de nous donner
d'un côté il y a des forces de l'ordre
qui sont sur le terrain qui vivent pas
forcément bien ce qu'elles font et vous
nous reprochez de ne pas assez souvent
leur rendre hommage j'ai envie de vous
répondre que j'ai l'impression que vous
ne rendez pas très souvent hommage à
leur victime aussi qui ont la bien vu
ces derniers temps étaient des balles
perdues des personnes qui étaient au
milieu des personnes qui ne devaient pas
être là Yazid il y a bubakar il y a tous
les autres
et donc il y a des questions qui
émergent au niveau de la police
notamment sur le fait de ces chiffres
que vous utilisez beaucoup à savoir
cette augmentation
ce que ce 1 cas toutes les 30 minutes
qui repose essentiellement quand même
sur l'augmentation du nombre des
contrôles et qui fait qu'il y a une
surcharge de travail
inutile pour toute une partie de nos
forces de l'ordre il y a de l'autre côté
la population qui s'inquiète de ces
morts de ses victimes de sa sécurité qui
ne s'améliore pas de ce sentiment que
quand on est pauvre on a un peu moins
droit à la sécurité que tous les autres
ça c'est un projet de société liberté
égalité fraternité
enfin et j'en terminerai là-dessus pour
essayer pour une fois de tenir mon temps
de parole
la Love Me monsieur le ministre est-ce
que ce sera encore une succession de
chiffres ou est-ce que pour une fois
vous accepterez d'écouter d'autres voix
de travailler en fin en sortant de la
caricature des écologistes et de la
gauche pour qu'on puisse offrir un
véritable projet au service des Français
et pas au service des chiffres merci
Monsieur Davy Reiman pour le groupe de
gauche
démocrate républicaine
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre j'ai écouté vos propos
introductifs qui parlaient des
travailleurs sans papiers vous utilisiez
même quelques quelques termes marxistes
donc je me dis qu'il faut que je profite
de ce moment pour pour vous parler de
ces travailleurs de des entreprises
Chronopost DPD RSI qui sont depuis un an
en grève pour obtenir leur
régularisation il y a un piquet de rêve
chez moi à Gennevilliers en matière
conscription ça fait un an que nous
essayons un dépôt collectif en
préfecture de leur dossier que les
services nous trimballe et que ça fait
un an que ces hommes qui pour beaucoup
ont traversé la Méditerranée durement
qui travaille qu'on travaillait pendant
le covid qui sont exploités par ces
sociétés du bâtiment et bien attendent
que quelque part l'État par le biais de
la préfecture disent et bien qu'il veut
les protéger et c'est ça qui est attendu
comme réponse donc comme on a beaucoup
de mal à obtenir
soit des rendez-vous soit des réponses
fermes je profite de de votre audition
pour pouvoir vous vous reformuler cette
question et vous demander si dans les
préfectures concernées vous pouvez aider
à ce que nous soyons pas simplement reçu
mais aussi que des réponses plus
pérennes et qui permettent leur
régularisation soit permis ça c'est la
première chose et la deuxième la semaine
dernière au village des alternatives un
festival citoyen voulait proposer des
solutions face aux enjeux sociaux et
environnementaux il y avait un atelier
de désobéissance civile chacun ici a le
droit de ne pas être d'accord avec ça la
question en revanche c'est que quand on
quand un préfet propose de leur couper
les subventions au nom du non-respect du
contrat d'engagement républicain et bien
je crois que c'est une atteinte
extrêmement grave au Liberté
fondamentales d'expression et
d'associations nous avions pointé déjà
ces dangers au moment de la loi
séparatisme au moment aussi des
prolongations des progressions d'état
d'urgence qui déjà s'attaquer à des
militants et une confusion entre
terroristes et citoyen de confusion
musulmane donc pour aller vite est-ce
que vous allez permettre que cette
association continue à avoir ces
subventions je vous remercie merci
Monsieur Miss vous pouvez répondre à
cette première série de questions étant
préciser qu'il en restera ensuite 27
tout augmente monsieur le Président et
des questions
alors beaucoup de questions je vais
essayer de d'y répondre
peut-être si vous ne permettez de la fin
au début
moi je suis prêt à vous recevoir dans
mes député avec le avec le collectif
moi-même si vous le souhaitez avec grand
plaisir et Monsieur le Préfet je me suis
penché cette question puisque m'a fait
remonter la demande je cru comprendre
que la demande régularisation concernait
le collectif et je ne peux pas y avoir
de régularisation collective il peut
avoir des révélation individuelles sur
lequel je suis prêt à aller la
contrepartie de la régulation
individuelle c'est que les gens ne
doivent pas être en contact avec ce
qu'on essaie de faire d'autres pays sur
justement les régularisations je prends
un exemple pour qu'on ne fait pas du
collectif je vais pas m'engager devant
vous faire 100% de collectif des
travailleurs sans papiers de Chronopost
imaginons que l'un d'entre eux est un
casier judiciaire je voudrais
régulariserai pas je vous le dis cette
personne en revanche vous avez tout à
fait raison comme j'ai dit on repos
introductif non mais bien sûr c'est
exceptionnel ça devrait aller donc ça
devrait aller c'est pour ça que je vous
dis que si on pose la question des
employeurs qui prennent des travailleurs
sans papiers qui sont les seuls à
pouvoir demander la régularisation
encore une fois je pense que c'est un
rapport de force qui n'est pas positif
pour le salarié vous savez bien si on
change ça dans la loi ce sera une bonne
chose bon et la deuxième des choses
effectivement si les personnes
travaillent souhaite s'intégrer à la
République moi ma ligne à moi
mais il y a moins que que je souhaite
qu'on nous porte dans le texte
immigration
c'est que nous soyons durs avec les
personnes qui soient étrangers
délinquants sur le sein national et que
nous puissions régulariser et aider ce
qui veulent travailler respectez les
lois de la République chose que ces
lignes toute républicaine toute
républicaine et il y a plein de gens qui
méritent sans doute d'être
régularisation et qui les ont pas
aujourd'hui et il y a plein de gens qui
les ont alors qu'ils devraient pas les
avoir depuis que je suis mise à
l'intérieur on a refusé 70 000 titres de
séjour pour des personnes qui les
avaient jadis automatiquement parce que
les agents préfecture ne regardaient pas
les casiers judiciaires avant de
renouveler les titres de séjour ça c'est
modifié et moi j'assume cette fermeté
sur ce point en revanche vous avez
parfaitement raison il y a des gens qui
travaillent depuis des années sur le
territoire de la République qui parle
français qui font des familles qui qui
parfois payent des cotisations des
impôts qui profite pas de cette
solidarité nationale auquel ils ont le
droit parce que l'employeur ne joue pas
si je veux dire le jeu légal donc moi je
recevrai madame députée et on regardera
les choses et on aura l'occasion d'en
reparler
madame madame rigole bon moi je suis un
peu étonné de votre de votre
intervention mais
on vous écoutant je si j'avais une
boutade je dirais je préfère la gauche
Rousselle à la gauche rigole parce que
voilà Monsieur Roussel je pense que ça
se voit qu'il y a pas de droite il y a
une circonscription difficile et que je
connais bien
non non mais on a le droit de parler de
Monsieur Roussel sans que ce soit une
insulte pour ses partenaires je sais pas
s'il vous plaît
que je puisse parler aussi sinon c'est
un jeu politique où je ne fais que vous
écoutez mais
oui mais moi j'aimerais bien plein de
choses mais on va peut-être si je peux
me permettre de me concentrer sur le
ministre donc voilà moi je vous dis que
Monsieur Roussel on a plein de
désaccords quand il évoque le fait qu'il
soutient comme ce matin encore parce que
j'écoutais la radio ce matin comme
contre vous qui le soutenait les
ouvriers de la sécurité comme ils
appellent les policiers je crois que
effectivement c'est plutôt la tendance
républicaine que j'ai pu rencontrer
depuis que j'ai l'âge de faire de la
politique et notamment à gauche et on
vous écoutant madame je comprends
pourquoi l'essentiel désormais d'une des
Français des forces de l'ordre en
particulier et c'est un tram parce que
ça pas toujours été le cas ou des
Français désormais disqualifie la gauche
que vous représentez pour les protéger
parce que justement la plus grande
politique de social c'est la protection
la protection des plus faibles et les
plus riches d'entre nous madame la
député ils n'ont pas besoin d'effectif
en plus ils ont pas besoin
ce que je peux terminer ma phrase s'il
vous plaît
les plus riches entre nous ils ont pas
besoin de force de police
supplémentaires ils ont pas besoin de
caméras de vidéoprotection ils ont déjà
par leur propre comportement parfois
leur propre mobilité ils ont quitté les
quartiers les plus populaires que
beaucoup d'entre nous connaissent ici
ils ont payé leur propre système de
sécurité et ils attendent de l'état de
la fermeté de la protection parce que
sans cette protection s'est terminée
sans les policiers de la République
d'ailleurs je voudrais dire ici qui sont
les enfants n'ont pas les enfants des
patrons du CAC 40 les enfants des
employés des ouvriers des commerçants de
France c'est les soldats de l'andouille
les policiers et les gendarmes et bien
c'est policiers ils méritent je crois
respect et quand on augmente de 100
euros par mois le policier c'est ce que
vous allez faire dans notre vie si vous
la votez 100 euros par mois je pense
qu'on augmente un ouvrier de la sécurité
voilà comme dirait
Fabien Roussel donc moi je partage pas
je partage pas vos attendus et j'ai été
assez scandalisé que vous parliez des
victimes des forces de l'ordre voilà je
je suis désolé et ça me permet
d'ailleurs de faire le lien avec la
France insoumise là aussi je suis
particulièrement
personnellement en particulier
comment comment vous l'expliquez une
expliciter sans
[Musique]
non je sais pas si j'arrive gentiment
parce que quand on dit que la police tue
monsieur bernalicis
je suis très poli madame mais s'il vous
plaît vous avez tous auditionné demandez
pas poser une question mise l'intérieur
laissez-le au moins répondre et ce qui
me paraît ce qui me paraît ce qui me
paraît intéressant ce qui me paraît
intéressant c'est quand on a la chance
comme nous tous de parler quand on a la
chance comme nous tous de parler
quand on a la chance comme nous tous de
parler à la télévision à la radio on
blesse des gens avec nos mots et quand
on dit que la France tu parles les
policiers quand on était policiers
assassinent on les laisse profondément
et je crois que c'est une blessure très
profonde qui a chez les policiers et les
gendarmes et que vous puissiez défendre
à la fois à la fois Monsieur et cuissen
qui est un islamiste radicalisé qui
explique que les Juifs sont un peuple
ingrat que des députés de députés de la
France insoumise les députés de la
France insoumise soutiennent que
Monsieur Guichen doit rester sur le
territoire national que fou et celui qui
fait le délicat quand les blés sont sous
la grêle madame la députée
oui aujourd'hui pour protéger nos
concitoyens notamment dire les plus
pauvres il faut expulser monsieur
cuyssen qui est un radicalisé et que il
se trouve des gens qui dans la même
intervention attaquent les policiers et
défendent un imam islamiste radicalisé
je me dis qu'il y a une cohérence
idéologique en effet dans votre propos
qui n'a rien à voir avec les textes
législatifs que l'on peut proposer c'est
un projet de société moi je le je le
respecte si je veux dire en tant que
idée politique mais que je combats que
je combats fortement et c'est un bon
compte que le préfet de la Vienne fait
son travail de préfet de la Vienne et il
a parfaitement raison et il a pris cette
initiative quand il a vu des choses qui
se passaient sur le territoire qu'il a
administré au nom de la République et je
le soutiens se présente la Commission en
est élu il pourra s'il veut s'exprimer
mais je le soutiens parfaitement la
République c'est pas n'importe quoi
n'importe où avec l'argent public voilà
c'est c'est peut-être aussi une
différence politique mais il faut qu'on
accepte d'avoir ces différences bien
évidemment
Monsieur le Maire a évoqué
Monsieur le Maire a évoqué le hub
européen de Nîmes mais il a bien raison
d'évoquer le hub européen de Nîmes qui
est une base
déjà qui fait honneur à la sécurité
civile française et c'est un point
d'ailleurs sur lequel monsieur le député
ça me permettra de répondre à Madame
Jacquin aussi l'idée que sur un endroit
on constate les moyens rien parce que
pendant le débat de ces feux de forêt on
a dit pourquoi il y avait pas d'avion du
côté de la Gironde pourquoi n'est pas à
Brest pourquoi n'avait pas dans le sud
sur un moyen on arrive à pouvoir
mutualiser un certain nombre d'outils
extrêmement techniques pour réparer
notamment les canadaires et on les
répare la nuit parce que les Canadiens
ne peuvent pas voler la nuit pour
éteindre les feux de forêts aucun
Canadair du monde ne le fait qu'elle
adhère ou autre appareil de n'importe
quel autre marque je peux pas faire
publicité particulier pour les canadairs
et on les répare la nuit pendant qu'ils
veulent le jour et parce que nous avons
des techniciens extrêmement spécialisés
avec du matériel extrêmement en pointe
qui est difficilement reproductible
d'ailleurs on le fait parfois pour
d'autres pays étrangers et donc oui
Nîmes est une base qui par ailleurs en
étant centrale dans le bassin du Sud on
va dire ça comme ça en quelques dizaines
de minutes intervient sur tel ou tel feu
parce que ce qu'il faut bien comprendre
que dans la sécurité civile et dans les
feux de forêt quand le feu s'est propagé
c'est déjà trop tard c'est juste dire et
vous devez déployer énormément de moyens
aériens et terrestre pour les éteindre
ce qu'il faut c'est les repérer très tôt
et ce qu'il faut c'est pas donc des
avions qui éteignent par
en quantité partout sur le territoire
national mais il faut partout des avions
des drones des hélicoptères vous avez
parlé des drones tout à l'heure qui
repèrent les feux de forêt naissants
c'est ça qui est important et dans une
des difficultés qu'on a eu en Gironde
mais on aura peut-être le temps de faire
un rétexte tous ces sujets en tout cas
président de la République nous l'a
demandé donc je le rendrai la commission
des lois si j'en est d'accord c'est le
temps d'alerte des services de secours
et manifestement Gironde ils ont été un
petit peu long pourquoi parce que c'est
dans une forêt toute particulière ou
d'ailleurs il y a eu un conflit d'usage
ou une partie d'associations ne voulait
pas qu'on entretienne cette forêt et le
non de retient de cette forêt puisque la
question m'a été aussi posée a causé la
propagation aussi du feu parce qu'il y
avait pas de chemin pour l'intervention
des pompiers où ils sont arrivés dans
des conditions extrêmement difficiles
par ailleurs il y avait l'atome donc le
feu s'est enterré par ailleurs il y
avait du vent donc vraiment c'était une
multiplication de facteurs très négatifs
mais si on arrive à entretenir les
forêts par ailleurs on arrive à repérer
par des moyens technologiques et par des
moyens humains alors oui on peut
utiliser Nîmes peut-être une deuxième
base parce on s'aperçoit que dans le
nord de la Loire désormais il y a des
feux il faut peut-être une deuxième base
dans le nord de la Loire à l'échelle des
cinq ou dix ans qui arrivent mais Nîmes
oui doit être le centre européen puisque
par ailleurs on voit bien que l'année
dernière on a eu très peu de feux de
forêt à l'exception du Var évidemment
mais en moyenne très peu de soirée on a
beaucoup aidé nos amis italiens nos amis
algériens nos amis grecs nos amis
israéliens nos amis espagnols cette
année c'est eux qui nous ont plutôt
aidés et que c'est le bassin
méditerranéen qui brûle et pas
simplement la France ou l'Espagne ou
l'Italie et qu'on a tout intérêt en
effet aux achats groupés au travail
groupé de nos pilotes et de nos
techniciens qui sont extrêmement
extrêmement courageux surtout que les
feux de forêts maintenant là nous sommes
tous rentrés si j'ose dire mais on
continue tous les jours il y a des
déclenchements de feu et jusqu'en la
Corse ce sera jusqu'au mois de décembre
donc il faut qu'on fasse extrêmement
attention des feux de forêt qui
désormais n'ont plus de saison et oui
vous avez raison la base européenne à
Nîmes c'est ce pourquoi nous nous
battons je reçois d'ailleurs bientôt le
commissaire en charge de la sécurité
civile le commissaire européen et je
l'amènerai à Nîmes pour pouvoir
constater l'excellence de cette base et
de et de ses pilotes vous avez aussi
posé comme Madame Jacquier Laforge
pardon pas Madame Jacquin j'en suis
désolé
vous avez déposé la question de la les
moyens de sapeurs-pompiers alors il y a
les moyens aériens et puis il y a les
moyens des sapeurs-pompiers les moyens
aériens bien sûr faut sans doute les
renforcer on a désormais la flotte la
plus moderne d'Europe on a également
renouvelé l'intégralité pour les années
qui viennent ça c'est prévu dans la Love
Me des crédits sont là de la flotte
d'hélicoptère en 35 hélicoptères en tout
mais je veux bien aussi vous assurer que
c'est pas qu'une question de moyens et
rien on a l'impression que quand
Canadiens ne viennent pas c'est qu'on
s'intéresse pas au feu mais le feu se
gagne souvent à terre
et par des retardants et par
l'intervention des colonnes de
sapeurs-pompiers et donc on a un travail
pas tellement de financement national
même si on peut toujours acheter des
canadaires ou des hélicoptères en
européen de façon supplémentaire on a un
travail de moyens de la sécurité civile
notamment l'été et notamment des
volontaires qui sont de moins en moins
présents dans les casernes parce que
leur employeur les laisse de moins en
moins aller dans les casernes et donc on
a un travail très important employeur
statut du volontaire qu'on a sauvegardé
à Bruxelles rappelez-vous parce qu'il y
a deux ans il était contesté on a aussi
un moyen des casernes rurales qui ne
connaissent pas le même nombre de
professionnels et de départements
pauvres qui ne peuvent pas embaucher un
nombre de professionnels au niveau et
donc il y a moyen de entre les 10 si je
veux dire de solidarité et puis il y a
une question de financement aujourd'hui
les 10 ils sont en partie
payés dans le fonctionnement par une
taxe sur les assurances qui est versée
au département mais qui n'est pas versé
intégralement
Osis et donc il y a un effet miroir par
le département qui sans doute
paye d'autres dépenses qu'on lui a
imposé donc c'est pas une critique
envers les élus départementaux qui font
que l'intégralité de la taxe pour lequel
on taxe les entreprises n'est pas versé
au département donc il y a un travail
très important désormais avec faire avec
l'adnf et avec la sécurité civile de
modernisation de notre appareil de
sécurité civile au nom du réchauffement
au nom du réchauffement climatique alors
vous avez posté des questions sur les
violences
intrafamiales notamment sur les
capacités de communication et de
plaintes donc les dispositifs pass
sécurité.fr mon commissariat.fr ma
brigade de gendarmerie.fr fonctionne
bien en information d'ailleurs je vous
commande tous de le télécharger vous
pouvez parler en direct et un policier
et un gendarme par chat pour lui
signaler un fait d'ailleurs une grande
partie des affaires de point deal que
nous que nous démembrons je rappelle
qu'on a fait baisser de 25% les points
de villes en France en 2 ans viennent de
l'application ma sécurité fr
effectivement dans les transports en
commun par exemple
pour tous ceux qui se font embêter dans
les transports en commun à commencer par
les femmes peuvent désormais sans
apparaître téléphoner ou appeler le 17
dire en direct sur leur téléphone en
chaton quel est leur difficulté mais
vous avez raison le sujet principal
c'est le recueil de plaintes alors on a
expérimenté plusieurs choses qu'on va
généraliser d'abord il y a le vert
aujourd'hui on n'a pas besoin de
dispositif législatif pour généraliser
ce qu'on a commencé à faire dans 3
départements de France c'est à dire que
des policiers des gendarmes vont soit
chez la victime soit chez quelqu'un que
choisit la victime leur mère leur
meilleure amie enfin qu'elle se leur
père qu'elle souhaite soit dans une
association par exemple de protection
des femmes soit ses cheveux avocat et
les policiers se déplacent et vont
prendre la plainte
commissariat ou qu'elle aille d'abord au
commissariat avec qu'elle perde
l'épreuve de son agression et bien
désormais nous généralisons les
conventions avec l'ensemble des centres
hospitaliers de France
alors
pour Monsieur Ciotti pour Monsieur
Ciotti
ça se voit que vous êtes en campagne
électorale parce que vous exagérez un
peu plus que d'habitude c'est c'est déjà
là
45% d'augmentation bon voilà bon je
rappelle les chiffres à Monsieur Ciotti
en 2017 2022 - 25% moins 25% mais on n'a
pas de non mais depuis 2012 pourquoi pas
depuis 1982 moi je suis né en 1982
les cambriolages de logements
monsieur cioti les cambriolages de
logements ont baissé de 25%. les vols de
véhicules de -21% les vols avec armes de
17% les vols violents sans arme de moins
31% les éruptions et gradations
volontaires de -15% en revanche vous
avez raison je l'ai toujours dit et
président de la République des relis par
la campagne les violences physiques aux
personnes augmentées et notamment je les
dis sur 100% des augmentations physiques
90% à cause des violences conjugales je
vous l'ai dit en 2022 le premier
semestre de l'année 2022 les résultats
sont moins bons je notais de le dire
mais moi c'est mon travail que dire
évidemment quand on m'interroge donc on
va on va voir ce qu'il ne fonctionne pas
améliorer les choses c'est parfois un
sujet d'organisation c'est parfois un
sujet d'effectif il y a plein de raisons
qui sont évoquées mais je pense que
voilà garder vos arguments
c'est un chiffre qui n'existe pas vos
45%. alors par contre vous avez vous
avez évoqué le fait que pour lutter
contre l'insécurité il y a plusieurs
ministères où il y a plusieurs
politiques publiques je suis d'accord
avec vous alors vous me dites pourquoi
j'ai pas fait une loi commune de
programmation commissaire de justice bah
d'abord on sait bien que c'est pas la
coutume monsieur se dit parce que vous
avez vous connaissez très bien les deux
lobsi les deux les deux les deux petits
des deux l'opsie précédente c'est
toujours le mystère qui les a porté mais
réjouissez-vous tressaie de joie comme
on dit vous allez avoir le mise de la
justice qui va venir devant vous
présenter une grande loi suite aux états
généraux de la justice de de pouvoir de
de renforcement des moyens de la justice
et sans doute
personnellement je l'espère deux
procédures pénales donc gardez votre
énergie pour monsieur le garde des
sceaux ce sera un très bon moment de
télévision j'imagine
du code pénal vous avez raison du code
du code et de procédure j'imagine qu'il
y aura des changements bon enfin
monsieur le garde des sourd le bonheur
discuter avec vous en plus vous partagez
les les mêmes goûts pour Nice donc vous
serez très heureux il faudra inviter
Monsieur Estrosi comme ça à trois vous
serez très heureux ensemble troisième
sujet monsieur Ciotti c'est pas c'est
pas tout à fait vrai qu'il n'y a pas de
simplification
monsieur Ciotti c'est pas tout à fait
vrai qu'il n'y a pas de simplifie de
simplification procédure pénal ou
d'action de la police dans la locmi il y
en a et d'ailleurs je pense que ça me
sera rapproché par une partie de
l'hémicycle donc vous verrez que c'est
pas tout à fait vrai même si je veux
bien dire volontiers que les articles
les plus importants les changements les
plus importants doivent être dans un
texte du cardio j'entends votre j'ai
entendu votre question sur les peines
plancher mais encore une fois il
appartient il appartient au garde des
sceaux de vos pompes sur ce point sur
l'immigration sur l'immigration monsieur
cioti il je sais pas où vous avez vu que
dans la lopine il va y avoir le taxi
migration ça jamais été le cas le texte
que j'ai présenté en mars dernier il n'y
avait aucune disposition sur
l'immigration on a même dit pendant la
campagne présidentielle qui aurait des
mesures émigration dont d'ailleurs les
suppressions de réservoir de public que
certains appellent la double peine mais
mais ce n'est pas ça n'a jamais été dans
la Love Me donc il y aura un deuxième
débat je pense qu'il est assez complexe
comme ça qui arrive bientôt en octobre
dans votre hémicycle en janvier dans
dans le Sénat procéda pardon puis
ensuite à l'Assemblée sur un texte
immigration me poser la question
d'augmentation des places ancra je pense
que vous avez mal lu la loopy monsieur
de député Ciotti il y a 700 places
prévues supplémentaires ne serait-ce que
dans les deux prochaines années bon on
aura l'occasion d'en parler de tous ces
de tous ces de tous ces sujets
la question m'a été posée par Monsieur
Boudry du enfin il a pas à poser de
question il a il a plutôt
évoqué des des opinions qu'il a qu'il a
cédé serait délinquants étranger et je
pense que là aussi vous vous caricaturez
vraiment
si je prends l'exemple de la dernière
année qui pourtant n'était pas très
édéante avec les difficultés sanitaires
que nous connaissons les tests PCR qu'on
devait imposer aux gens qui partaient du
territoire national on a expulsé
étrangers délinquants c'est une
augmentation de 60% de ce qu'on faisait
l'année d'avant hors covid voilà donc je
pense que ça sert à rien de caricaturer
pour appuyer votre propos
je signale d'ailleurs que les moyens
budgétaires que vous évoquez donc vous
vous moquez je sais pas
si on rencontre les mêmes policiers mais
en l'occurrence monsieur député vous
n'avez jamais voté ces crédits quand je
dis vous c'est votre vous représentants
politiques d'ailleurs ils ont voté
d'ailleurs aucun texte de sécurité et
même Le Pen a même réussi à se féliciter
le pas voté ce qui était un moment
étonnant de télévision non non les
papoter à disposition oui mais c'est
parti de sécurité globale c'est la même
chose dans votre souci de voter contre
tout ce que je propose vous englobez
tout mais non non c'est elle a voté
cette nouvelle mais elle n'a pas voté
séparatisme et la même combattu
fortement le séparatif de l'expliquant
qu'elle était liberticide que ça
réglerait rien elle a réussi pour le
burkini à son satisfaire elle a réussi
pour l'imami QC n'a sans satisfaire donc
ça risque deux fois satisfaits d'un
texte n'est pas voté donc moi je vous
encourage à regarder les choses de
manière non non politicienne après le
fait monsieur monsieur député que vous
soyez un policier
ça fait plusieurs fois que vous sortez
cet argument je suis pas sûr que ce soit
un très bon argument
il peut y avoir des des bouchers qui
font de la politique et qui étaient des
mauvais bouchés il peut avoir des
Poissonniers qui font la petite qui sont
des mauvais poissonniers donc je suis
pas sûr que le fait que vous étiez
policier
soit en soi un argument me semble-t-il
en tout cas c'est un argument de
facilité je vous encourage peut-être
pour le bien de la sécurité à désormais
épouser une position plus générale
peut-être moi moi dogmatique voilà et
plus complexe je reproche pas de t'avoir
été maire d'une ville difficile
mais
s'il vous plaît pour tous vous avez
interrogé le ministre de l'Intérieur
dans vos mots et avec vos expressions il
vous répond donc si vous pouvez faire
l'honneur de au moins vous taire quand
il vous répond ce serait appréciable
pour tous ceux qui attendent des
réponses d'accord
c'est l'apprentissage de la démocratie
parlementaire monsieur le Président vous
avez raison j'ai essayé de interrompre
les gens quand ils me m'interpellait
voir qu'il était quasi insulte mais on
va essayer d'avoir la même échange donc
en tout cas voilà en regardant les
choses dans les faits il y a jamais eu
autant de moyens pour la police et
gendarmerie que depuis que le Président
de la République était manuel Macron
c'est une vérité et on aura l'occasion
d'en reparler madame une terre meilleure
pardon a évoqué la réforme de la de la
police nationale de même que Madame
guivelou bon c'est un point très
important évidemment
qu'est-ce qu'on essaye de faire et moi
je me réjouis la mission de la formation
de Monsieur Bernay ici c'est Madame
givenou le Sénat fait mission
d'information et je suis d'ailleurs en
mesure de vous dire que j'ai saisi l'IGA
et l'IGPN pour également avoir un audit
sur les territoires expérimentaux et ça
tombe très bien puisque si c'est 3 mois
chacun si j'ai bien compris votre
démonstration et même si c'est 6 mois
puisque la love me passe d'abord au
Sénat donc ce sera dans le temps on en
tirera toutes des conclusions de des
audits et des missions parlementaires
donc le texte de loi madame est un maire
n'y voyait pas un agenda caché
simplement il se trouve que pour pouvoir
faire adopter quelque chose vous le
savez bien il faut l'écrire pour
qu'éventuellement deux ans après le
texte de loi soit adopté donc il n'y
aura pas il n'y aura pas de
généralisation de la réforme de la
police nationale si nous considérons
tous collectivement exécutif et le
Parlement que c'est négatif puisque par
exemple vous votez l'article premier de
la lothmique et le rapport annexée qui
prévoit la réforme de la police
nationale donc n'y voyez pas de de de
force de force cachée par contre on peut
revenir rapidement puisque madame et
vous-même m'interrogez sur pourquoi
c'est très fort
la police nationale est une structure
qui travaille en silo
un contrat Rio d'autres structures qui
ne travaillent pas en silo je pense à la
gendarmerie nationale où je pense la
préfecture de police c'est l'histoire de
la police nationale qui l'a voulu
insiste n'est pas une critique c'est un
constat et moi je peux constater que
ayant été maire d'une commune
qui travaille toujours travailler avec
les policiers depuis deux ans que je
suis mise à l'intérieur je constate
comme tous les ministres de l'intérieur
avant moi puisque cette réforme a été
pensée par Jox madame eltonamer donc
elle devrait culturellement vous
intéresser bon
nous avons des silos
nous avons des silos qui ne se parlent
pas toujours
la police judiciaire les renseignements
territoriaux la sécurité publique
l'ordre public et CRS
le souci du ministre de l'intérieur
c'est que tout le monde se parle et
qu'on soit plus efficient parce que la
question qu'il faut se poser c'est ce
que c'est efficace dans une organisation
quelle qu'elle soit et singulièrement
lorsqu'on dirige une administration on
ne fait pas une administration pour
elle-même ou pour ses fonctionnaires on
l'a fait pour le service public que l'on
rend moi je constate que la criminalité
a énormément muté on parlera du cyber et
pas une question pour l'instant sur ce
sujet mais c'est un sujet absolument
énorme la moitié des crédits du
ministère intérieur sont sur ce point
la voiture du du voleur est devenu
technologique elle utilise des moyens de
captation très différentes des écouter
téléphoniques d'hier elle travaille dans
un réseau international et désormais
tous les enquêtes de police ou la quasi
intégralité des enquête de police que
j'ai à ma connaissance montre que entre
le grand trafiquant de drogue qui a
Dubaï et le point de deal qui est à côté
de chez vous le lien est souvent
extrêmement fort
par ailleurs il y a des taux
d'élucidation qui sont en baisse pour la
police judiciaire là encore c'est pas
une critique c'est un constat année
après année
Macron nous résolvons de moins en moins
dans le cas judiciaire notamment parce
qu'il y a une technologie
on pourra reparler lorsqu'on parlera
peut-être de technologie un jour on a
parlé dans la loi terroriste le comme
tout le monde passe sur WhatsApp et sur
telegram les écoutes téléphoniques ont
désormais moins d'efficacité bon donc il
y a une baisse plutôt des lucidation il
y a une technologie d'action de la
criminel et puis il y a une organisation
en silo c'est tellement une organisation
aussi madame la députée que j'ai parfois
vu des services de police faire entre
eux des conventions pour travailler
ensemble
sécurité publique PJ c'est quand même un
drôle de moment où vous dites il faut
que deux chefs de services de la même
maison dans le même ministère doivent
discuter pendant quelques semaines et
faire des conventions pour parler
ensemble donc la réforme de la police
elle est d'autant plus importante que
par ailleurs vous en tant que député ou
le préfet ou la préfète ou simplement
leurs collègues gendarmes qui sont
organisés comme cela sont dans un
département
atomisés en plusieurs directions il y a
un directeur de la sécurité publique ou
une directrice un directeur une
directrice de la PAF un directeur ou une
directrice de la police judiciaire un
directeur une directrice et harcèlement
etc etc et lorsque par exemple vous
arrêtez quelqu'un vous interpellez
quelqu'un imaginons quelqu'un qui a
donné un coup de couteau on peut se
demander si c'est ce coup de couteau
est-ce qu'il relève du terrorisme bien
sûr ça c'est la qualification juridique
du parquet qu'il le dit ou est-ce que ça
relève d'une organisation criminelle ou
est-ce que ça relève du couteau si j'ose
dire gratuit au coin de la rue
qui se saisit de cette affaire si cette
personne est un étranger il faut
qu'évidemment un lien avec la police aux
frontières puisque la politique du
gouvernement vous l'aurez compris c'est
de reconduire cette personne dans son
pays de lui retirer son titre s'il avait
un titre et de le conduire dans son pays
peut-être que une note du renseignement
on l'a vu dans la faire Samuel Paty
appuyez des difficultés mais cette
tendance enseignement pour des raisons
de silo n'est pas arrivé sur les bons
bureaux au moment où nous en parlons
c'est vrai sur ce cas là c'est vrai sur
plein d'autres cas des faits divers que
nous avons connus y compris d'ordre
public et sans doute que le service
d'investigation qui s'en occupe si ma
vision que ce soit le commissariat du
coin a besoin d'expertise de la
préjudiciaire sur des sujets
technologiques ou sur des sujets de ben
voilà ce monsieur qui a de la coup de
couteau il se trouve qu'on le connaît
dans un grand réseau international de
drogue de vol de voiture et aujourd'hui
on manque ce silo d'information donc
l'idée qui est une direction unique de
la police nationale dans notre pays ce
qui n'est pas le cas aujourd'hui et une
direction unique par département préparé
une idée qui avait eu jadis monsieur Jox
conforme alors entre-temps il y a un
certain nombre de questions qui se pose
et que vous avez évoqué vous avez évoqué
l'autonomie finalement de la police
judiciaire elle sera renforcée la police
judiciaire elle passera de 5000
personnes à 20 000 personnes puisque
l'intégralité de la filière
investigation dont on ne pensons tous je
reçois vos lettres quel que soit les les
familles politiques vous voyez qui
manque des OPJ bah oui d'accord très
bien donc il faut en tirer des
conséquences aussi la police judiciaire
ce sera désormais plus de 20000
personnes et non pas 5000 ce qui
permettra d'ailleurs une évolution de
carrière beaucoup plus intéressante et
je le dis ici pas un policier qui fait
la police judiciaire de fera autre chose
que la police judiciaire demain
deuxièmement je peux comprendre la
question qui se pose sur les
départements il y a des gens qui me
disent oui vous avez raison votre
réforme est bonne mais sur la police
judiciaire quand la criminalise qu'on a
criminalité est organisée en dehors des
frontières d'un département il faut pas
les limiter au département je leur
répond oui nous allons mettre en place
plus que dans la première version de la
réforme des antennes régionales
qui recouvreront peu auproux les bassins
de délinquance qui travaillent déjà à
peu près comme cela aujourd'hui avec des
chefs de fila j'imagine à Marseille à
Bordeaux enfin bref un peu partout sur
le territoire national troisièmement me
dit
dans les affaires financières du coup on
sera moins intéressé puisque le préfet
aura l'info et pour parler aux députés
ou au mur du coin bon moi j'ai dirigé la
Direction Départementale les directions
départementales des finances publiques
je pense pas que tu es préférée avaient
les informations sur les contrôles
fiscaux et si ils en avaient ils
prévenaient rarement les élus bon donc
pendant trois ans j'ai vu comment
fonctionne
un grand réseau qui a fait la fusion
comptabilité publique contrôle finance
publique c'est exactement les mêmes
critiques à l'époque d'ailleurs c'est la
gauche qu'il l'avait fait très très
ridicquée par la droite et c'est nous
qui si je veux dire avons mis la poêle à
source et donc la fusion des total des
deux administrations bah non il y a un
directeur départemental unique des
finances publiques il y a pas un type
qui s'occupe de la comptabilité publique
une dame qui s'occupe du contrôle
fiscaux tout directeur qui s'occupe de
la papeterie qui s'occupe des voitures
qui s'occupent des RH qui s'occupent des
bureaux mais chacun a son métier et ils
le font bien sans donner des
informations alors ce qu'il y a de la
comptabilité publique oui au préfet mais
pas d'information confidentielle du
secret fiscal qui relève du du secret
évidemment de la procédure mais on
imaginant que vous ayez raison c'est
tellement
délicat donc j'ai proposé je le dis
devant la commission parce que je suis
pas sûr que quelqu'un allait déjà
entendu que toutes les questions de
probité qui concerneront les chefs
d'entreprise les élus enfin tous ceux
qui pourraient avoir des questions de
lien avec les pouvoirs publics seront
fait non pas au niveau départemental
mais au niveau zonal donc imaginons que
ça arrive à Tourcoing et bien ce sera
dépaysé et ce sera l'antenne régionale
qui s'occupe de ce sujet pour pas que ce
soit le préfet de département qui sont
en porte-à-faux avec leur directeur
départemental qui aurait l'information
sur une enquête judiciaire
dernier point vous dites l'autonomie va
avoir des magistrats mais qui choisit le
service d'enquête
qui fait faire des actes d'enquête c'est
pas moi qui dirige les policiers les
gendarmes sur le terrain lorsqu'il y a
des interpellations et des actes
d'enquête à faire c'est bien des
magistrats des procureurs ou des juges
c'est pour ça d'ailleurs que la police
municipale n'est pas obligée parce que
rappelez-vous la loi sécurité globale on
nous a dit mais si vous voulez que les
policiers fassent des petites même des
petites des passages fichiers des
amendes de forfaitaire des rituels des
choses qui relèvent de la préjudiciaire
c'est procureur qui prend la main et
c'est plus le maire et les maires de
France on dit bah non non on garde notre
police municipale j'avais quelque part
plus de pouvoir quand je gérais la
police municipale de Tourcoing sur les
contrôles que depuis que je suis mise à
l'intérieur moi je ne fais que donner au
procureur de la République et au juge
des policiers des gendarmes qui agissent
sur l'enquête alors ensuite le préfet
bien évidemment mais comme c'est le cas
aujourd'hui madame la députée il a un
intérêt dans la sécurité de son
département et pour pour bien qu'il ait
et ça fait partie du travail que nous
menons contre la délinquance toutes les
informations qui lui permettent de
lutter contre la sécurité il faut que
les renseignements la police aux
frontières l'investigation la sécurité
publique parle et pas qu'on fasse la
réunionite ou des silos moi je trouve
que la préjudiciaire fait un travail
formidable de modernité et il faut
simplement qu'elle se modernise bien
évidemment et je suis toujours à leur
écoute et je serais très attentif aux
travaux de l'hégia et des parlementaires
voilà ce que je veux dire en quelques
mots peut-être dire à Madame givevenou
que sur les jeux je rendrai après deux
réunions qui vont m'occuper les 15
prochains jours un certain nombre
d'arbitrages sur la présence des forces
et le nombre des forces nécessaires mais
je n'ai pas encore tout à fait des
dispositions à lui donner je peux déjà
dire que nous annulons une grande partie
des congés des préfets des agents
préfecture des forces de l'ordre pour
l'été 2024 mais ça ne se prendra
personne
merci Monsieur millise donc une deuxième
salle de question monsieur Boudier oui
merci monsieur le Président d'abord sur
la locmin monsieur le ministre et merci
de pour cette audition devant la
commission des lois sur la locmi
sans doute que le principal point se
texte c'est la trajectoire financière
budgétaire que vous proposerez sur 5 ans
c'est une innovation majeure en termes
de force de l'ordre de sécurité publique
à l'image des lois de programmation
militaire et pour je le dis pour mon ami
eriki un concernant ces insatisfactions
nous aurons à travailler monsieur le
ministre sur la copie du Sénat qui
saisit en première lecture et donc nous
travaillerons bien sur la copie des
sénateurs dont une partie significative
appartiennent aux républicains Amérique
centines ne m'écoutent plus depuis
quelques temps et j'en suis j'en suis
déçu
je voudrais passer un autre sujet si
vous le permettez monsieur le ministre
qui est les conséquences vous l'avez
évoqué
un petit peu de la loi séparative votez
il y a maintenant un an à peu près un
peu plus vous avez noté les outils
juridiques vous les avez rappelé qui ont
permis à l'état d'être plus puissant
beaucoup plus fort notamment dans la
lutte contre l'islamisme politique la
capacité de l'État à répondre à l'enjeu
du burkini vous l'avez noté tout à
l'heure la capacité à rendre expulsable
animal qui avait prononcé des propos
tout à fait contraires au principe de la
République c'est le résultat de la loi
séparatiste mais je voudrais faire appel
au ministre des Cultes sur des points
supplémentaires de ce texte sur le
séparatisme nous avons adopté et
notamment le résultat le bilan vous
tirez un an après concernant la réforme
des statuts des lois 1905 des
associations de loi 1905 a eu un débat
assez fort y compris d'ailleurs avec les
cultes sur ce sujet je le sentiment
qu'aujourd'hui les choses sont très
apaisées dans l'exécution dans
l'application conquête
ce texte la nécessité de séparer des
activités culturelles et culturelles
parce que c'est là que le terreau entre
du séparatisme parfois ce fait nous
l'avions évoqué à plusieurs reprises
nous n'avions donc musclé les conditions
de statut des lois 1901 qu'en est-il
aujourd'hui peut-être un focus pardon
monsieur le Président mais sur la
traçabilité des financements extérieurs
qu'il a aussi été un enjeu de sécurité
publique important merci Monsieur
Boudier monsieur Yoann Gillet
oui monsieur le ministre la ville de
Nîmes ville la préfecture du Gard situé
dans ma circonscription est aujourd'hui
gangrené par l'insécurité fin août dans
le quartier du Chemin malavignon un
homme sous contrôle judiciaire depuis
plus de deux ans a percuté violemment
une femme qui s'est retrouvée écrasée
contre un mur fin août toujours un
incendie criminel a touché l'école du
Mas roman un acte intolérable survenu
presque un an jour pour jour après
l'incendie qui avait touché l'école Paul
Langevin dans le quartier de Pise 20 il
y a une dizaine de jours une jeune femme
était agressée sexuellement en pleine
rue par un mineur isolé les trafics de
stupéfiants sont présents dans toute la
ville au quotidien les armes circulent
et sont d'ailleurs utilisés fréquemment
pour des règlements de comptes pour des
tirs d'intimidation entre bande rivales
également les quartiers du chemin
balavignon depuis 20 de Valdegour et du
Mas de Mingue sont particulièrement
gangrenés par ces trafics et la présence
importante d'armes les quartiers
résidentiels autour de ces quartiers eux
aussi comme le centre-ville et également
les villages voisins sont impactés
fortement par la criminalité les
homicides tentative se multiplient à
Nîmes je n'exagère pas la situation
monsieur le ministre je ne fais que
décrire la ville de Nîmes et ses
quartiers devenus des zones de
non-frances où les policiers sont
devenus des cibles prioritaires les
services se secours et professionnels de
santé sont depuis des années
régulièrement contraints d'y être
protégé pour pouvoir intervenir les
facteurs font quant à eux leur travail
avec la crainte de se faire agresser les
caillassages de bus du réseau de
transport sont nombreux contraignant
régulièrement les chauffeurs à exercer
leur droit de retrait l'ultra-violence
continue de s'intensifier aucune réponse
n'est apportée par le gouvernement il y
a trois semaines vous annonciez un
renfort de policiers dans certaines
villes mais Nîmes n'étaient pas
concernés je profite de vous avoir en
face monsieur le ministre pour vous
rappeler qu'en juillet dernier le
parlementaire que je suis qui a un
contrôle un rôle de contrôle de l'action
gouvernementale vous a demandé un
certain nombre de données chiffrées sur
l'insécurité de ma circonscription et
qu'à ce jour vous n'avez pas déni me
répondre alors bien sûr vous me
répondrez avec des chiffres ce des
postes supplémentaires de ces dernières
années et j'en termine vous oublierez en
revanche de parler et d'effectifs et
vous ne comparerez que les périodes qui
vous arrangent comme vous le faites
régulièrement monsieur le ministre il
est temps de permettre au gardois et aux
Français de vivre en sécurité quand
allez-vous cesser de détourner le regard
quand ce gouvernement va-t-il faire
rendre aux zones de gens
Monsieur léonan
Merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre
la question que je vous pose en fait
c'est une question qui me vient des
pompiers de la Meuse où j'étais en
déplacement et je leur ai dit on voit
monsieur Darmanin la semaine prochaine
donc si vous aviez une question à lui
poser quelle serait elle donc je
rapporte les propos des pompiers de la
Meuse la première c'est ils nous disent
on a besoin de moyens et notamment de
moyens pour se fournir en matériel le
deuxième sujet c'est la perte de sens
beaucoup d'entre eux m'ont dit que il y
avait une perte de sens de leur travail
parce que de plus en plus ils sont
obligés de faire des missions qui sont
en réalité celles qui d'habitude sont
celles des assurances et notamment des
assurances enfin des des pardon des
ambulances privées qui est le transport
de personnes et il me dit à la fin d'une
journée finalement on a l'impression
d'avoir fait essentiellement ça la
troisième question qui se pose c'est la
question des salaires parce que les
salaires il y a des disparités assez
énormes en fonction des départements et
dans leur cas en l'occurrence avec le
département d'à côté c'est des
disparités des des une différence qui
sont de l'ordre de 400 euros quand même
ce qui n'est pas une petite différence
et qui n'est pas une petite motivation
pour le travail et enfin la dernière
question c'était celle de de
l'organisation réelle du service des
pompiers et qui au final va rejoindre
aussi la question des salaires qui est
que c'est une organisation
départementale alors que parfois il y a
des missions qui pourraient être
entendues comme l'émission nationale et
je pense notamment à la lutte contre les
incendies et je rappelle ici que les
pompiers qui veulent lutter contre les
incendies qui sont des pompiers
professionnels doivent se mettre comme
pompier volontaire pour aller sur des
incendies donc ils font leur semaine
ensuite ils sont volontaires ils vont
sur les incendies et à la fin il
recommence une semaine de travail à la
suite de ça donc ça c'est un des
problèmes ça pose des problèmes en
termes de fatigue mais aussi en termes
d'efficacité pour aller sur ces
incendies puis enfin dernière question
qui m'ont posé c'est la réintégration
des pompiers suspendus parce que ils ont
un peu mal vécu pour certains d'entre
eux le fait que on fasse venir des
pompiers de l'étranger sans sans
s'interroger sur leur statut vaccinal et
que des pompiers français n'est pas pu
participer à la lutte contre les
incendies alors que ils étaient
disponibles pour le faire merci Monsieur
Poget
en visio
merci président monsieur le ministre
avec ma collègue Alexandra Martin député
de Cannes nous avons attiré votre
attention dernièrement sur le manque
d'effectif sur la commune de Vallauris
Golfe-Juan dans les Alpes-Maritimes
actuellement c'est le maire et sa police
municipale qui compense ce manque de
moyens alors que comme dans de
nombreuses autres communes on constate
une recrudescence de violence de vol ou
même de rodéo qu'en est-il de notre
demande mais surtout les effectifs
supplémentaires que vous avez annoncé
pour les Alpes-Maritimes et dont nous
vous remercions seront-ils équitablement
répartis sur l'ensemble du territoire
monsieur le ministre votre projet de loi
vise à donner plus de moyens humains
juridiques et matériels intérieur je
m'en réjouis les intentions sont
louables mais comme il s'agit d'une loi
d'orientation nous serons vigilants
quant aux actes néanmoins un regret très
fort il semblerait disposition ne vienne
renforcer les prérogatives des polices
municipales afin qu'elles puissent être
considérées réellement comme la
troisième force de sécurité de notre
pays je pense tout particulièrement et
vous venez d'en parler aux missions de
contrôle alcoolisme stupéfiant identité
ou alors d'accès à certains fichiers
quels sont vos intentions quant à la
place des polices municipales dans notre
pays leur rôle et commence surtout les
rendre plus efficientes parce que ce
sont des moyens à la charge des communes
et des mers merci
merci Monsieur Balanant
madame des Jonquières
merci président monsieur le ministre le
21 août dernier l'hôpital de
Corbeil-Essonnes a été victime d'une
attaque par rançon officielle pardon qui
a gravement affecté son fonctionnement
cette attaque qui a été revendiquée par
le groupe de hacker le Big 3.0 illustre
l'augmentation des attaques par range
son logiciel dans le secteur de la santé
face à cela l'État a toujours recommandé
de ne pas payer les rançons exigées
lundi rappeler garçon guide pour les sur
les attaques par range son logiciel de
2020 que le paiement incité et les
cybercriminels à poursuivre leurs
activités et entretenir donc ce système
frauduleux pourtant le projet de loi
d'orientation et de programmation du
ministère de l'Intérieur la locmi que
vous portez que nous allons
prochainement examiner au Parlement
comporte un article l'article 4 du
projet de loi qui prévoit
l'indemnisation des assurés en cas de
paiement d'une rançon la conditionnant
au dépôt de plainte rapide cette mesure
semble traduire un changement de
doctrine de la part de l'État à l'égard
de la lutte contre les rangions du ciel
ne craignez-vous pas que cette
disposition envoie un signal négatif et
rejoindre une recrudescence de ce type
d'attaque envers les entreprises et les
établissements français qui
deviendraient des cibles
particulièrement luttes créatives pour
les hackers également le départ le dépôt
de plainte en cas de cyberattaque est
une étape essentielle dans la lutte
contre la cybercriminalité les forces de
l'ordre sont déjà sensibilisés formés
pour recueillir ce type de peinte on
peut noter ici le pas très positif
justement franchi par exemple avec la
création des premières et compagnies en
école de gendarmerie cependant comment
entendez-vous favoriser toujours plus la
formation et la sensibilisation de nos
policiers de nos en de nos gendarmes au
risque cyber merci
merci Madame car mon lit
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre chers collègues
je voulais juste rebondir par rapport à
un certain nombre de questions qui ont
été posées et des réponses que vous avez
apportées monsieur le ministre
puisque on a parlé de plein de sujets
finalement aujourd'hui qui concerne qui
touche le ministère en fait je voulais
vous faire d'abord revenir un peu sur
une réponse que vous avez faite
concernant la police judiciaire en
réponse à ma collègue Cécile vraiment
ailleurs vous savez parler de 20000
postes en tout cas d'enquêteurs
finalement
je suis la police judiciaire et je ré
souhaitais donc savoir quel est
justement la part de création parmi ces
postes est-ce qu'il ne s'agit pas d'un
redéploiement des moyens
entre voilà de personnes qui travaillent
dans notre service donc ça serait
important
deuxième élément qui change un peu de
sujet mais je voulais vous profiter de
de cette réunion aujourd'hui pour vous
faire part d'un certain nombre de
réactions dans nos départements et
préfectures concernant l'attribution des
renouvellement des papiers l'identité
passeport ou carte d'identité et plus
particulièrement il s'agit vraiment de
renouvellement et pas de nouvelles
attribution c'est des personnes qui ont
un certain âge plus de 60 ans et que je
trouve aujourd'hui y compris dans mon
département parce qu'ils sont d'origine
algérienne etc et de revenir leur
demander de prouver leur nationalité
vous imaginez le choc pour ces personnes
qui ont eu fonctionnaires et lecteurs
qui avait à plusieurs reprises leur
carte d'identité au bout de 62 ans 70
ans parce qu'il devait faire un voyage
en leur demande de prouver leur
nationalité est-ce qu'il y a eu des
instructions qui ont été données est-ce
qu'il c'est une voilà comment vous
pouvez expliquer moi je n'ai pas de mort
pour expliquer en tout cas ces personnes
qui nous est saisissent merci beaucoup
monsieur le ministre merci Monsieur
Pradal
merci Monsieur président monsieur le
ministre une question très rapide qui
fait le lien sur les titres d'identité
nous avons tous observé un certain délai
en logement des délais pour
l'établissement des titres d'identité
Vous avez été amené afin de répondre à
aux besoins qui étaient créés mettre en
place un plan d'urgence c'est ce que
nous pourrions avoir quelques retours
sur ce plan d'urgence et surtout savoir
si certaines mesures de ce plan
d'urgence ont vocation à être
pérennisées
et merci beaucoup pour brief et Monsieur
Pradal monsieur Lucas merci Monsieur le
Ministre j'étais ce matin à Dunkerque
pour observer et comprendre la réalité
de votre politique migratoire arrivé aux
abords du camp de Loon-Plage je me suis
vu refusé l'accès par le commissaire de
police présent il m'a été demandé de me
tenir éloigné du périmètre d'une
opération de je cite mise à l'abri quasi
hebdomadaire qui n'a visiblement pas
rencontré de succès puisque une seule
personne est montée dans le bus de 50
places qui avait été affrêter pour
l'occasion en revanche j'ai vu des
dizaines de familles partir résignées
épuisés leur bagages sur le dos leurs
enfants à la main pour s'installer dans
un champ de terre humide à quelques
dizaines de mètres de là alors rencontre
et à celle des associations j'ai entendu
une demande une supplique un robinet
un robinet pour accéder à l'eau potable
à l'eau potable et je le répète une
seconde fois quelle nation soucieuse des
droits de l'homme peut refuser un accès
permanent à l'eau potable à quiconque
est sur son sol ces associations ont
alerté sur une politique qui empêche
dans les faits les exilés de faire
valoir leurs droits d'alerter si elles
sont victimes et qui les exclut de tant
d'informations juridiques nécessaires ma
question est simple monsieur le ministre
et vous avez fait entrer un peu de
politique politicienne alors je vais
faire de même avons-nous fait barrage à
l'extrême droite le 24 avril dernier
pour que des hommes des femmes des
enfants vivent dans de telles conditions
que les associations qui leur viennent
en aide soient harcelées empêchées et si
souvent injurier avons-nous sauver la
République dans les urnes pour qu'elle
soit assis bafouée dans les camps de
fortunes que la France offre pour seul
accueil à ceux qui ont fui les guerres
et la misère vous disiez il y a quelques
mois Madame Le Pen trop molle nous
découvrons jour après jour que ce
n'était pas qu'une formule mais un aveu
pire un programme et un style celui d'un
Sarkozy discount
le président monsieur le ministre
bonjour alors Monsieur le Ministre les
territoires d'outre-mer sont confrontés
à des problèmes sécurité majeurs le taux
de criminalité de mur bien supérieur à
ceux de la France hexagonale en matière
de criminalité la délinquance la gaine
continue d'avoir la palme de mauvais
records les données du service
statistique ministériel de la sécurité
intérieure sont particulièrement
éloquantes prenons l'ensemble des
territoires français entre 2016 et 2021
la moins s'établissait à 1,2 homicide
pour 1000 habitants
multiplions ce taux par 9 pour la Guyane
plus précisément 9,33 pour obtenir le
taux d'homicide en Guyane sur la même
période conclusion la situation est
mauvaise depuis bien longtemps en 1996
déjà des milliers de personnes c'était
réunies de les rues de Cayenne pour
dénoncer la sécurité puis en 98 et ainsi
de suite mais la sécurité perdure et les
manifestations pour la dénoncer sont
devenues répétitives cycliques pour ne
pas dire
usuel
devons-nous continuer à laisser la
Guyane c'est être stigmatisé catégorisé
comme l'un des territoires de France les
plus criminogènes
où pouvons-nous enfin acté
officiellement l'échec des politiques
gouvernementales à chaque fois on
complète de connexion de nos réalités
la souffrance système d'une population
détresse ne se sentent pas à coup
d'opération antidécence ni accoudoirs
des effectifs de police et de
gendarmerie alors je suis ravi monsieur
le ministre que s'apprête à doter votre
ministère du moins humain juridique et
budgétaire inédit mais quoi nous à la
source les mots qui infectent la société
guyanaise quand on fait l'état
prendra-t-il en compte les réalités de
nos territoires plutôt que de s'obstiner
alors calquer les méthodes du territoire
hexagonal
de nos réalités pour la mise en oeuvre
de politique on adéquation avec celle-ci
qui seront gage de réussite enfin
monsieur le ministre je vous ai envoyé
un courrier hier où est-ce que je vous
demande lors de votre passage en Guyane
très bientôt de vous rendre à
Saint-Laurent-du-Maroni donc il est la
capitale de l'ouest et qui est aussi une
ville frontalière pour voir la réalité
de Saint-Laurent merci à vous merci
monsieur le ministre vous pouvez
répondre à cette deuxième salle de
gestion
pardon
merci monsieur le Président pour la
Guyane vous allez la gentillesse de dire
que je me rendais avec une mise à
justice et le ministre des comptes
publics en charge des douanes le
week-end prochain ce sera l'occasion de
rencontrer Monsieur le Député parce que
je viens à la demande du président de la
collectivité qui nous invite à vous
assise de la sécurité puisque vous
l'avez raison la Guyane est touchée
depuis plusieurs semaines mais on fait
on le sait depuis son endémique depuis
plusieurs années par une délinquance
extrêmement forte qui vient de plusieurs
raisons une pauvreté évidente mais aussi
de difficultés frontalières de drogue
très présente sur le territoire guyanais
comme comme vous le savez et
j'aurai l'occasion sans doute d'évoquer
le fait que c'est pas des effectifs
supplémentaires en effet qui a besoin la
Guyane puisque ils ont eu une
augmentation extrêmement importante
d'effectif il y a même 4 escadons de
gendarmerie mobile à demeure désormais
en Guyane je crois qu'il y a pas de
territoire à l'exception de Mayotte qui
connaissent un tel déploiement policier
mais évidemment les réponses sont plus
interministérielles plus générales et
sont parfois dans les portefeuilles des
autres ministères puisque les policiers
gendarmes vous le savez bien subissent
beaucoup de difficultés et notamment la
présence très forte qu'ils ont dans les
opérations harpies puisque il y a même
sur les quatre escadron deux escadrons
de gendarmerie mobile qui essayent avec
nos amis militaires de pouvoir éviter
des pillages de ressources naturelles et
de ressources tout court qui sont l'une
des difficultés de la Guyane pas la
seule bien évidemment et qui prennent
aussi beaucoup de moyens et donc la
question se pose du succès de ces
opérations et la façon dont on doit
organiser les choses par ailleurs on
sait tous que l'aéroport de Guyane est
une difficulté particulière de l'arrivée
des mulets et de la drogue sur le
territoire européen de manière générale
et créer une sorte de dépendance
évidemment avec des gens qui prennent
des risques incroyables en ingurgitant
un kilo 2 kg de cocaïne parfois des des
mères seuls des des étrangers se soient
régulières qu'on exploite pour cela et
donc on aura l'occasion voilà dans une
semaine je crois de répondre à votre
interrogation je ne sais pas si j'aurai
l'occasion d'aller à
Saint-Laurent-du-Maroni puisque je dois
aller en Martinique juste après mais je
le ferais bien volontiers surtout je
suis allé quatre fois depuis que je
m'intéresse à ces questions on avait
rouvrir une une
d'État supplémentaire le président de la
République son dernier déplacement et je
suis d'accord avec vous que
Saint-Laurent plus Saint Georges de
l'autre côté sont aussi des lieux qui
concentrent avec Cayenne et difficultés
les plus importantes j'en ai
parfaitement conscient monsieur des
monsieur députés sur Dunkerque je pense
pas que vous ayez sauvé la République
mais vous avez l'air d'être convaincu
cela moi j'ai plutôt vu le Front
national voté avec la France insoumise
dans mon élection législatives à moi
mais n'hésitez pas n'hésitez pas
n'hésitez pas non non au second tour
j'étais face à la France insoumise et
voilà à la nupes et j'ai plutôt vu j'ai
plutôt vu ce genre
j'ai plutôt vu ce genre de j'ai plutôt
vu ce genre de comportement électoral je
suis heureux que vous puissiez vous
rendre compte sur place s'il vous plaît
s'il vous plaît
le ministre n'a pas commenté les
questions
mais n'hésitez pas la prochaine fois
quand je serai quand je serai au second
tour d'élection la prochaine fois
n'hésitez pas à appeler à voter au
second tour évidemment
je crois que votre présentation de ce
qui se passe à Dunkerque et de manière
ce qui se passe on peut dire dans
l'ensemble de la Côte d'Opale et je
crois qu'il y a d'autres parlementaires
qui sont ici je vois un député du
Pas-de-Calais extrêmement au fait ces
questions et qui subit comme mère puis
comme parlementaire ces questions depuis
bien longtemps et tout à fait contraire
à la vérité de ce qui se passe d'abord
je pense que nous et la commission c'est
beaucoup penché sur cette question
nous mentirions aux Français et nous
montrerions aussi aux migrants si nous
pensons que la solution elle n'est que
française et je veux rappeler ici que si
60% des personnes qui sont entre
Dunkerque et la Somme et qui veulent
passer en Angleterre
Dunkerque le Calais marquise
oies plage c'est des villes magnifiques
je m'y suis marié donc je suis très
heureux de Boulogne-sur-Mer mais c'est
pas pour la beauté des paysages à cause
de Pal que les migrants traversent
l'Afrique l'Asie la Méditerranée pour
venir dans le nord de la France malgré
la beauté encore une fois nos paysages
ils veulent aller en Angleterre
donc je pense que c'est une d'abord une
situation subie pour les migrants bien
évidemment et pour la population
française donc je veux dire ici que les
populations Nord-Pas-de-Calais au sens
large du terme font preuve d'une énorme
patience tellement leur vie personnelle
et coupée par ses difficultés et les
difficultés des migrants ne sont pas
incompatibles avec les difficultés des
habitants et discuter des habitants sont
pas incompatibles avec les difficultés
des migrants mais 60% de ces personnes
soient éligibles à l'asile 4% seulement
déposent nos îles en France pourtant les
services du ministère de l'Intérieur et
si c'était le contraire je pense que les
associations le diraient bien plus que
ça
essaye tous les jours de leur dire
déposer l'asile en France ils ne veulent
pas déposer ma ville en France qui ne
veut pas rester en France et quand vous
dites qu'on fait des opérations de mise
à l'abri par ailleurs vous dénoncez le
fait qu'il est dans un champ c'est
justement les questions que vous devriez
vous poser parce que les opérations mise
à l'abri il y a 11000 logements
logements libres aujourd'hui dans la
grande région des Hauts de France qui ne
sont pas occupés des chambres d'hôtel
réquisitionnées il y en a deux à
Tourcoing d'ailleurs des hôtels
réquisitionnés pour cela que nous
accueillons bien volontiers ou là il y a
de l'eau il y a l'électricité il y a du
gaz il y a du chauffage il y a des
vêtements il y a un accompagnement
social et il y a malheureusement des
organisations et vous avez l'air de les
soutenir qui veulent soustraire à ces
opérations de mise à l'abri où nous ne
faisons d'ailleurs aucun contrôle
d'identité je voudrais ici de rappeler
pour les mettre effectivement dans
d'autres territoires de la République et
notamment dans la France mais ils ne
veulent pas y aller parce qu'ils veulent
aller en Angleterre ils veulent pas
rester sur le territoire national ils
veulent aller en Angleterre où ils ont
et c'est bien normal à la fois de la
famille on l'a vu dans le drame des 27
migrants retrouvés morts dans la Manche
l'hiver dernier on a vu qui rejoignait
sa fiancée ou son financé ses parents et
ses enfants et nous ferions sans doute
pareil si nous étions à leur place mais
aussi par un système d'organisation du
Code du travail britannique qui fait que
l'immigration irrégulière y est je le
dis une nouvelle fois encouragé et
malgré les annonces du bonhomme
britannique nous n'y avons pas vu nous
n'avons pas vu de changement pour
l'instant de la politique migratoire
britannique monsieur Johnson a fait
croire qu'en sortant du brexit comme
certains ici en sortant de l'Europe on
pourrait mettre pas à émigration
évidemment il n'en n'a pas été question
une seconde et aujourd'hui que nous
avons ces difficultés donc ces
opérations mises à l'abri sur le
comptable ce que vous dites c'est
justement parce que ces opérations des
abris parfois fonctionnent parfois ne
fonctionne pas que les personnes n'ont
pas accès à l'eau n'ont pas accès à
l'alimentation ou non pas accès au
chauffage alors qu'il y a des bébés il y
a des difficultés et il y a aussi dans
ces camps de migrants énormément de
violences du fait qu'une grande partie
d'entre eux sont exploitées par des
passeurs par exemple avec des
assassinats vous le savez dans cette
situation donc cette situation me paraît
le contraire de ce que vous évoquez la
solution à cette situation c'est ce que
nous essayons de faire c'est difficile
évidemment ça fait 30 ans que le
Nord-Pas-de-Calais cette situation même
si aujourd'hui il y a 15 fois moins de
migrants qu'il y en avait il y a 6 ans
15 fois moins de migrants qui avait 6
ans et le premier le premier travail
positif a été fait par Bernard Cazeneuve
on le sait tous dans le démantelant la
jungle de Calais il faut éviter de se de
se reconstituer et bien nous avons à
difficulté aujourd'hui à convaincre nos
amis britanniques de faire un traité
européen pour qu'ils puissent enfin
comprendre qu'il y a des flux classiques
normaux des immigrations vers la
Grande-Bretagne puisqu'on peut parler
jeudi à l'ensemble ici
la Grande-Bretagne c'est à peu près un
million d'étrangers et ces 3000
expulsions par an 3000 expulsions par an
et donc quand certains disent que le
modèle l'immigration c'est de modèle
britannique on a toujours pas vu les
retours des migrants au Rwanda parce
qu'évidemment c'est absolument
impossible un pays qui a la CEDH et
l'organisation est absolument contraire
à la façon dont on peut expulser des
personnes sur un territoire et donc les
Britanniques sont obligés de constater
que lorsque des migrants arrivent sur
leur sol ils ont quasiment une chance à
100% de rester sur ce sol là voilà donc
je crois que vous vous trompez
d'adversaires sur ce point je pense
qu'il y a beaucoup de raisons pour
lesquelles on peut se poser mais
vraiment je crains que la démonstration
d'inhumanité est plutôt du côté des
passeurs que du côté des forces de la
République et des préfets
le troisième mais bien sûr si les
victimes le déposer plainte ils peuvent
déposer plainte mais si on fait des
opérations de mise à l'abri c'est
justement pour qu'ils puissent avoir des
chambres d'hôtel de l'eau du chauffage
du gaz voilà donc il faut absolument
qu'on ne reconstitue pas des jeunes
puisque c'est le contraire c'est le
contraire de l'humanité que vous
défendez il faut que puisse mettre dans
des hôtels dans des lieux dans des lieux
de résidence où les gens peuvent déposer
leurs papiers soigner leurs enfants
vivre au maximum comme il le souhaite
vivre parce que sinon vous faites un
marché pour les passeurs et c'est ce qui
a mené le travail d'humanisme avec des
guillemets ça a donné à l'exploitation
des personnes d'êtres humains c'est le
contraire de ce que vous souhaitez et
c'est pourtant la cause de vos actions
politiques malheureusement le sujet sur
l'investigation et la police judiciaire
vous avez raison Madame la Députée c'est
une question très très importante des
moyens supplémentaires pour
l'investigation
quelle est la difficulté quelle mise à
l'intérieur est donc qu'à la commission
des lois si j'ose dire en tant que
intérieur je ne peux affecter dans des
commissariats dans des services de
police que ceux qui sortent d'école de
police
c'est à dire que ma marge pour faire ici
j'ai entendu des gens qui me disaient il
y a pas assez d'effectifs il y a pas ce
truc là bon très bien je suis tout à
fait d'accord et j'ai moi-même contribué
à ce genre de demande lorsque j'étais
élu mais on doit tous comprendre c'est
pour ça qu'on change un certain nombre
de choses que les mises intérieur quel
qu'il soit ne peut affecter que les
sortants d'écoles
et ensuite dans la vie du policier du
gendarme on ouvre des postes
le gendarme c'est plus facile parce
qu'il a statue militaire mais c'est pas
toujours pas toujours le cas pas
toujours le cas il en manque par exemple
une dizaine à la brigade de Mamoudzou
absent petite terre aussi enfin voilà
donc c'est pas toujours le cas mais
c'est plus facile avec les militaires
comme cette unités
au commissaire Tourcoing et si les gens
ne candidat pas sur les postes de PSG
mais ça tourne je ne peux pas les forcer
et
pour une de ces raisons qui sont le
manque de pilotage qu'elle mise à
l'intérieur sur ses effectifs mais on
propose évidemment des choses et
notamment la raison de la police
nationale pour en partie réparer ça par
le fait qu'il manque de PJ devant des
enquêtes aujourd'hui il manque à peu
près 5000 OPJ devant des enquêtes il en
faudrait à peu près 22000 pour quelque
chose aille mieux le mieux possible vu
le niveau de notre délinquance une
partie de ces origines ne sont pas dans
des enquêtes il y a des gens qui
touchent des primes PJ qui sont au PJ
mais qui sont renseignement territoriaux
ça ça n'a pas d'intérêt puisque
forcément territorial vous ne faites pas
d'enquête judiciaire donc voilà on a
changé un certain nombre de choses on a
retiré les prix on retire les primes des
personnes qui sont territoriaux pour
doubler la prime obéji de ceux qui
acceptent devant des enquêtes il y a une
question évidemment de procédure pénale
et de simplification j'y reviendrai pas
mais qui est quand même importante pour
leur travail d'où les assistants
d'enquête et puis madame il y a une
question d'évolution le problème de
l'OPJ dans un commissariat c'est que
quand il est à la brigade
sur les violences intrafamiliales après
comme on a peur de le faire partir parce
que
et c'est sans doute vrai dans les
endroits les plus compliqués de la
République du coup il n'a pas de
promotion et ça se dit dans les services
et donc vous n'allez acceptez pas d'être
finalement OPJ vous pourriez faire
pendant quatre ans cinq ans six ans pour
une période de votre vie par exemple la
cellule drogue ou la cellule famille tel
commissariat mais si vous savez que vous
avez une possibilité d'évolution après
mais comme c'était des comme c'est des
comme je vous l'ai expliqué les
directions en silo on a du mal sur un
effectif vous voyez de permettre une
promotion plus grande puisque plus il y
a des effectifs et bien plus on arrive à
ses promotions et d'où en partie la
réforme de police nationale ou
l'ensemble de l'investigation du
commissaire secteur jusqu'au grand
offices financiers ou criminels seront
dans la même direction nationale
préjudiciaire alors qu'est-ce qu'on va
faire notamment pour parler des
effectifs pour être extrêmement concrets
dans la loi précédente j'ai fait adopter
au Parlement l'idée que désormais le
gardien de la paix et le gendarme
feraient 12 mois de formation et non
plus 8 mois seulement de formation
d'ailleurs je dis à chacune et à chacun
puisqu'on va poser les questions de la
façon dont les policiers genre se
comportaient c'est ce gouvernement qui
augmente et en tout cas soumise à
l'intérieur qui augmente le nombre de
mois de formation
sur ces quatre points de formation il
placeront le passeront le bloc OPG
pourquoi j'ai besoin d'un texte de loi
parce que aujourd'hui pour avoir le PJ
il faut passer un concours spécifique
trois ans au minimum après votre école
de gardien de la paix donc vous êtes
gardien de la paix vous avez fait un an
et en sortant on vous dit vous devez
attendre trois ans pour passer votre
qualification de PJ nous on a considéré
que c'était une disposition absurde donc
on vous propose de la faire sauter pour
que dès la sortie d'école de police
pendant la formation on puisse passer le
bloc OPJ ça veut pas dire qu'ils
l'auront il y en aura sans doute de
tiers qui ne l'auront pas c'est pas très
grave d'abord ils auront des formations
juridiques ça fait une mal à personne et
puis même si un tiers seulement il
arrive ou quand bien même ils auraient
une première partie pas une deuxième
partie le concours est inchangé toujours
sur la présidence des magistrats c'est
pas la police qui préside le ni la
gendarmerie qui préside le concours OPJ
je pourrais donc affecter dans les
commissariats dans vos services des
policiers pas simplement de sécurité
publique mais des spécifiques qui auront
la qualification judiciaire et donc
parmi je peux pas vous répondre
exactement que ça dépend évidemment vous
l'aurez compris des allées venus des
ouvertures de poste qui dépendent pas du
ministre mais de la loi de l'offre et
d'allemand si vous le permettez comme ça
parmi les
1500 policiers de sécurité publique que
je vais mettre dans les commissariats
partout en France il y aura un certain
nombre d'entre tous ceux qui ont reçu le
concours courant déjà l'obji et que je
pourrais directement nommer dans des
commissaires ce qui n'est pas le cas
aujourd'hui je terminerai par dire cette
question elle est cruciale parce que
plus on met personne sur la voie
publique plus on interpelle de personnes
plus on fait d'enquête évidemment plus
on a besoin d'enquêteurs par définition
et qu'on a besoin des présenter ensuite
au magistrat et que la bonne procédure
judiciaire fait par des gens du temps de
qualité juridiques permet une bonne
condamnation pénale je lis d'ailleurs
aux policiers aux gendarmes parfois il
râle sur un syndrome de réponses pénale
et on s'aperçoit que c'est un défaut de
procédure qui est du fait du policier du
gendarme qui a mal fait sa procédure et
c'est bien normal qu'en République on
condamne des gens sur des bonnes bonnes
procédures donc pardon
et donc je je serai pas être très
crédible en défendant les policiers
monsieur bernalicis c'est peut-être pas
la peine de rajouter vous avez un autre
forme de beauté et oui c'est pas
celle-là donc je pense que sur ce point
particulier on a on a un meilleur une
meilleure investigation par la réforme
j'espère vous avoir en partie convaincu
sur sur ce point vous avez beaucoup été
monsieur Pradal et Madame
la député également sur la question des
pièces d'identité alors faut que vous
sachiez ce qui s'est passé pendant le
covid les gens n'ont pas renouvelé leur
pièce d'identité parce que on bouge plus
de chez nous on prenait plus l'avion
puisque les pays d'avion et donc on
renouvelle peu sa pièce d'identité
surtout quand les services municipaux et
les préfectures sont fermés pendant le
covid et donc la carte d'identité qui
valait 10 ans le passeport qui va dix
ans on a perdu un an et demi deux ans et
arrivant le concours des étudiants
arrivant le moment on passe son permis
de conduire et le moment où on va
prendre un billet d'avion pour partir en
vacances pour venir professionnel les
gens se sont réveillés en disant
compliqué les autres idées pas à jour
alors il y a eu des erreurs faites par
l'administration il y a des erreurs en
partie faite par les collectivités
locales et il y a eu ce bouchon fait par
les personnes notamment à l'épreuve de
l'été 2022 vous l'aurez constaté les
heures d'administration c'est pas
forcément d'avoir anticipé totalement
cette question je veux bien l'avouer on
a débloqué 400 postes supplémentaires
pour l'entaille parce que c'est une
agence qui fait ces pièces d'identité-là
aujourd'hui on est passé grosso modo de
100 100 jours d'attente en juin dernier
à 45 jours d'attente en moyenne donc
c'est déjà trop puisqu'il faudrait une
trentaine de jours d'attentes 38 38
jours maintenant voilà donc tout tout
fonctionne c'est 30 jours c'était le
l'équivalent de ce qui se passait avant
la crise donc on est quasiment à la
normale sauf dans quelques territoires
on a encore un petit peu d'attente
d'ailleurs je le dis nous avons encore
des machines de prise de rendez-vous et
de pièces d'entités possibles à mettre à
disposition des mairies et toutes les
machines ne sont pas prises aujourd'hui
par toutes les communes à qui on le
propose donc retournez-vous si vous le
souhaitez ouvrir vos préfets il peut
vous débloquer un certain nombre de
difficultés la difficulté des commune
c'est que quand les gens ont vu que
c'est des bouchonner ils ont fait
plusieurs rendez-vous et donc ils ont
joué sur plusieurs communes ou plusieurs
départements et on s'est aperçu que
cette multiplication parce qu'il est pas
affiché unique et affichée par
département cette multiplication de
prise de rendez-vous pour essayer de
maximiser une fois à Paris une fois à
Lille si je veux dire ça plaise
d'identité pris par l'envie de se
déplacer et ben évidemment
il y avait des gens qui avaient pris un
rendez-vous qui venait pas parce que ils
avaient un rendez-vous à Paris et ça
donc thrombosé notre système on a attiré
les conclusions on va faire afficher
unique des prises de rendez-vous pour la
prochaine fois on a on a effectivement
eu cette difficulté la troisième
difficulté c'est qu'une partie quand
même des postes étaient encore en
télétravail et qu'on a mis un petit peu
de mal à à répondre à la demande on a
quand même trouvé un certain nombre de
facilités notamment pour les étudiants
on leur a permis de venir avec une pièce
d'identité périmée mais bien sûr c'est
un regret de pas pouvoir avoir rendu
l'intégralité des pièces d'identité
alors moi je veux dire à Monsieur le
Député du Gard
d'abord il est une présentation un peu
noir de son territoire
ça donne pas très envie de venir chez
vous mais
oui oui
non parlez pas du maire de Nîmes s'il
vous plaît ce serait pas bon aujourd'hui
parce que vous m'avez demandé des
chiffres c'est bizarre d'intention vous
dites je vous ai demandé chiffre vous
n'avez pas répondu puis vous dit de
toute façon vous avez des chiffres je
m'en fous bon c'est grosso modo
les chiffres parce que sinon on serait
capable de me reprocher de pas vous
avoir donné malgré le fait que vous
n'aimez pas les chiffres
sur le député parce que sinon ça va être
un peu difficile ou alors vous vous êtes
d'intervention politique et vous avez
pas envie de ma réponse ce que j'aurais
pu comprendre parce que je fais aussi de
la politique mais dans ces cas-là je me
fatigue pas beaucoup donc si vous voulez
que je vous réponde monsieur député on
est passé dans votre commissariat donc
de 210 effectifs nets actifs à 312
effectivement
il y a donc de 2017 à 2022 monsieur
voilà alors n'hésitez pas à dire s'il
vous plaît
une relation
dans la commission mais dans ce cas là
il va falloir expliquer au 22 d'entre
nous qui pourront pas parler pourquoi
ils ont pas parlé et c'est 22 là c'est
vos collègues de vos groupes que ce sont
les groupes les plus pourvus qui
n'auront pas la parole si on continue
danse comme ça d'accord donc si on peut
manger
demain matin
dans la situation du Gard et notamment
de Nîmes je voudrais vous dire que
effectivement sous le quinquennat
précédent puisque vous parliez des
chiffres moins 43% de vol violent moins
38% de vol de véhicule - 34 % de
cambriolage 15 tonnes de cannabis saisie
dans l'ensemble du département du Gard
parce que vous êtes un passage entre
l'Espagne malheureusement et le reste du
pays notamment la zone sud mais pas que
l'Île-de-France et moins 34% de
cambriolages oui une augmentation de
violence aux personnes comme partout sur
le territoire national je l'ai dit ce
député il y a aucun problème avec cela
et pourquoi vous avez pas eu de
renforcement de CRS parce que justement
vous aviez eu une augmentation
d'effectif de police qui est équivalent
de Mayotte il y a eu en proportion à
Nîmes l'augmentation de policiers que
j'ai moi-même je suis venu trois fois à
Nîmes en deux ans j'ai pas le bonheur de
vous connaître mais maintenant je suis
sûr que je réalise je serai très heureux
de vous rencontrer puis j'ai même fait
plusieurs tournées avec la police
nationale ne vous en inquiétez pas et je
vois très bien quels sont leurs
difficultés la difficulté du Gard est de
Nîmes c'est que le meilleur pays
marseillais les touches désormais voilà
et donc il serait plus juste de dire que
s'il y a une augmentation de la
délinquance faite aux personnes qui sont
notamment dû au règlement de compte
parce que justement la police la justice
comme dans le Vaucluse le gars c'est
comme le Vaucluse c'est les mêmes
difficultés une augmentation réglement
de compte parce qu'une augmentation des
procédures judiciaires et des
interpellations plus de 35 % est appelée
drogue rien que les deux dernières
années monsieur député c'est parce que
la police s'agisse fait son travail dans
des conditions vous avez raison
difficiles et il y a une bataille pour
la République à gagner évidemment dans
ces deux territoires là du fait
notamment de la difficulté de Marseille
et comme à Marseille on met énormément
de moyens et qu'on arrive à faire
reculer le trafic de drogue notamment
avec quartier Nord il y a une tendance
et c'est bien logique puisque en luttant
quand tu as des vacances d'un côté et la
tendance à reproduire vu l'argent qui
s'y fait facile ailleurs notamment dans
le Bocuse dans le Gard et donc j'aurai
l'occasion sans doute d'en reparler avec
vous si vous souhaitez dans un cadre
peut-être un peu moins un peu moins
violent mais pourquoi pas sur le terrain
si vous le souhaitez quand on met plus
de 100 policiers supplémentaires faire
en net dans un commissariat dans une
ville comme Nîmes je crois qu'on peut
considérer enfin je sais pas si chacun a
eu 6 plus de 100 policiers comme ça dans
son commissariat monsieur le monsieur le
Président que la République fait son
fait son fais son rendez-vous la
question qui m'a été posée sur la Meuse
alors d'abord bonjour aux pompiers de la
Meuse avec grand plaisir
leur dire que je comprends leurs
questions de perte de sens puisque ce
que vous évoquez monsieur le député
c'est le fait que aujourd'hui 80%
intervention des pompiers sur les
interventions dites de santé ou de ce
cours personne ce qu'on appelle des
carences parce que la loi matras a en
grande partie essayé de résoudre par une
augmentation des tarifs de facturation
au département par les départements à
l'assurance maladie mais qui évidemment
n'est pas satisfaisante parce que vous
avez parfaitement raison de dire que les
pompiers aujourd'hui et notamment sans
doute dans votre département que je
connais moins bien que le mien mais moi
en tout cas dans le mien ils viennent
dans le monde rural au moins mais
parfois dans mon urbain aussi comblé le
manque de médecins et au moment de Pitot
où le manque de service des urgences et
donc vous avez raison mais aujourd'hui
c'est eux on se travaille il faut
absolument qu'avec les mises à la santé
c'est travail qui fait contre les désert
médicaux contre les fermetures de lieu
d'hôpitaux plus on mettra le médecin
plus on aidera les filières santé moins
les pompiers on va faire ce travail et
je comprends tout à fait vous avez
parfaitement raison que c'est carence on
donne beaucoup de pattes de sens le
matériel j'entends ce que vous dites
mais c'est une compétence du conseil
départemental totalement décentralisée
je pense que la décentralisation faut
qu'on accepte l'idée que si on n'est pas
décentralisation c'est ceux qui ont le
pouvoir qui décident donc là c'est un
sujet entre vous et le conseil
départemental de la Meuse
n'hésitez pas mais on est prêt à
regarder on l'a déjà dit de revoir le
financement de 16-10 qui peut être n'est
pas assez assez moderne ou acide amnique
et sur la question que vous évoquez des
des pompiers suspendus je pense que
c'est une question plus générale de ceux
qui n'ont pas accepté la vaccination
pendant le covid c'est vrai des pompiers
c'est vrai des médecins c'est vrai de
pas mal de professionnels je trouve que
c'est au ministre de la Santé de vous
répondre sur cette question je voudrais
vous dire que ceux qu'on a fait venir y
compris les Polynésiens on a vérifié
qu'ils étaient vaccinés pour répondre à
votre interpellation évoquée puisque
vous évoquez un certain nombre de
personnes qui viendrait d'ailleurs et
qui n'aurait pas été sollicité après
volontaire professionnelle je serais
vous enfin il faut qu'on en parle un peu
plus parce que 60 % des pompiers
professionnels sont aussi volontaires et
c'est tout oui mais c'est pas un système
si négatif que ça quand le pompier
professionnel de Lille habite dans sa
caserne rurale parce que sinon vous ne
tenez pas les caserne rurales des
pompiers et si vous voulez mettre tout
le monde en professionnel ce qui est
parfois une revendication d'un symptôme
de syndicats mais c'est tout ce qui est
pompé professionnel ils sont payés par
nature plus ça coûte plus cher enfin
tous les élus de terrain tous ceux qui
ont été élus qu'on s'est départementaux
et pour gérer un département le savent
ça coûte plus cher donc il y a une
question de financement voilà donc
il y a un travail autour de cela mais le
pompier professionnel volontaire
toute la profession n'est pas absolument
d'accord sur cette position vous le
savez bien mais il y a sans doute une
question de sous et une question de
département les petits départements
ruraux quand parfois des feux de forêts
plus importants et plus de déserts
médicaux sans doute comme le vôtre alors
peut-être pas pour les feux de forêt
les pompiers des dessins c'est un bon
exemple ils ont pas de ils ont même
financement par la taxe
des assurances et pourtant ils ont pas
de sephorer en Essonne en tout cas pas
ma connaissance il faudrait sans doute
qu'on regarde comment on aide les
départements qui ont des déserts
médicaux ça doit être sans doute le
carneton parce que des grandes villes
qui non mais il y a des grandes villes
la moyenne
absolument partout et deuxièmement
comment bon je suis invité par le
président aller plus vite donc je vais
aller plus vite et
d'accord et donc et donc répondre à la
question des des financements je pense
que ça sera un sujet très important des
des mois des mois à venir
la question sur le sur le pouvoir de
Monsieur alors monsieur le député de des
Alpes-Maritimes m'a posé la question de
la répartition des effectifs de police
pour écouter vu le nombre d'effectifs du
pays ce que jeûne au préfet des
Alpes-Maritimes je crois qu'il sera le
mieux placé pour dire où vont-ils dans
quelques mystérieurs mais tout le monde
sera servi si j'ose dire une CRS
monsieur ce type là c'est dommage une
CRS supplémentaire 60 effectifs au 31
octobre d'autres l'année prochaine voilà
donc je pense que il est tout à fait
normal que les communes que vous avez
citées connaissent sans augmentation je
ferai un petit message au préfet des
Alpes-Maritimes mais je crois que vous
le connaissez aussi bien que moi donc il
est à sa disposition qui s'effectif
arrive au 31 octobre non il y a pas
disposition pour la police municipale
Monsieur le Maire j'allais dire monsieur
député je le regrette voici mais le
Conseil constitutionnel a été très clair
on a été au maximum et pouvoir qu'on
pourrait donner aux police municipale si
vous voulez donner le pouvoir au police
municipal il faut changer la
constitution ou donner la police
municipale au procureur de la République
pour les actions judiciaires moi je
respecte la loi de la République et les
inconnus du la constitutionnel donc on
ne peut pas à droit constant sauf si les
maires acceptent qu'on délègue leur
police municipale au procure de la
République ce qui n'est pas je crois le
cas des mers alors on peut pas pour
l'instant améliorer les choses mais nous
avons fait des choses de très
intéressantes à la sécurité globale
accès aux fichiers SUV smpsc fourrière
FPR c'était une grosse question c'est
SPR et 10 m sont permis par la loi
sécurité globale les quatre premiers
sont déjà possibles pour les polices
municipales les trois autres sont en
train d'être finalisés et donc la loi
sécurité globale connaît son application
enfin pour répondre à Monsieur Boudier
vous avez parfaitement raison sur la loi
séparatisme sur la question
ils ont trois ans vous le savez pour
passer d'un statut d'un statut à l'autre
moi je remercie le recteur de la Mosquée
de Paris qui a accepté de transformer la
Mosquée de Paris de l'an 1920-1905 c'est
un symbole c'est la mosquée la plus
importante que nous avons sur notre sol
il rentre complètement dans le cadre
républicain avec la déclaration de tous
les financements étrangers lorsqu'il y
en a
voilà ça je pense que c'est le modèle
qu'on doit obtenir aujourd'hui les
préférés réunis les associations
cultuelles mais qui touchent
singulièrement les musulmans puisque je
rappelle que les Juifs sont des juin
1905 les protestants aussi et les
catholiques ont des diocésaines qui
équivaut à 1905 donc il s'agit
essentiellement des protestants et de
quelques lieux de culte évangéliste et
donc ils sont en train de passer vers
vers 1905 et distinguer effectivement
culturel du cultuel je veux en profiter
pour dire que les sur les 2000 600
lieues de culte musulman qui que compte
la République il y en avait une centaine
lorsque je suis devenu mise à
l'intérieur qui était soupçonné de
radicalisation de séparatisme 30 ont été
fermés d'une manière ou d'une autre et
notamment grâce à la loi séparatisme 30
sont sortis de ses radars
parce que les contrôles ont été faits
parce qu'il y a un changement d'imam
quand on leur a demandé parce qu'il y a
un changement de financement quand on a
demandé parce qu'un changement de
dirigeant quand on l'a demandé et encore
une trentaine qui sont en train d'être
contrôlés par les services du ministère
de l'Intérieur
merci monsieur le ministre pour pouvoir
pour pouvoir terminer
question
pour pouvoir parvenir au bout de la
liste des orateurs je vous propose de
réduire significativement le temps de
parole à une minute et donc je donne la
parole à Madame Abadie
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre vous nous avez dit allez voir
de renforcer les effectifs sur la
cybercriminalité alors j'aurais voulu
savoir comment cela va s'articuler avec
farose la plateforme de signalement qui
puisse la création de 2009 à recueilli
un million et demi de signalement je
crois que sur une année pleine c'est
plus de 270000 par an
10% pour des caractères discriminatoires
55% d'escroquerie et 3% sur de
l'apologie du terrorisme alors malgré
cette activité importante moi j'avais
noté que les effectifs étaient que de 28
enquêteurs c'est toujours 7 de plus
qu'en 2016 je voulais savoir où en était
ces effectifs arrose le Premier ministre
Castex avait dit qu'il voulait les
renforcer et une question sur la
prévention lors de votre première
audition en commission des lois on avait
échangé sur le permis internet cette
prévention que les forces de l'ordre
font dans les écoles et on a subi deux
événements forts la covid mais aussi la
généralisation de cette prévention lors
de la loi de séparatisme je voulais
savoir où on en était de se découvrement
merci merci Monsieur Guitton
oui merci monsieur le Président Monsieur
le Ministre donc je vais aller très vite
puisque on a déjà su dénoncé beaucoup
les l'augmentation finalement donc du
nombre d'agressions et de fait
délinquance en France et moi j'aimerais
revenir notamment dans la ruralité donc
en tant que débuter de l'aube je
souhaite attiré votre attention le
ministre sur la hausse de délinquance
qui date pas d'hier sur les secteurs
agricoles et viticoles le territoire de
la côte des barres notamment dans l'Aube
représente un ancien pagement d'environ
8000 hectares de vigne et connaît un
accroissement très important de
travailleurs pour les vendanges pour nos
viticulteurs les vendanges constituent
la période la plus importante de leur
travail et donc nécessaire de protéger
la population et leur infrastructure
qu'à leur préjudice peuvent être très
conséquents pour lutter contre ces
délinquance dans le secteur viticole il
y a eu un dispositif de sécurité dans
l'Aube et aussi dans la Marne avec 4
réservistes une brigade mobile voilà des
personnages gendarmerie mobiles aussi en
vélo qui ont été mis en place
pouvez-vous donc nous informer de de ces
conséquences qui sont tirées est-ce
qu'il y a eu des évolutions en termes en
termes de lutte contre l'insécurité et
vous le reproduire ce dispositif ces
prochaines années ensuite vous nous
proposez la création de 200 brigades de
gendarmerie et doublement de la présence
de nos forces de l'ordre sur le terrain
d'ici 2030 comptez-vous
côtez-vous finalement avec les élus
locaux leur demander leur avis et
comment cela va se faire parce que vous
avez parlé de deux à trois gendarmerie
par département je vous remercie merci
Monsieur Benali
merci monsieur le ministre je reviens
sur la question de la police judiciaire
alors on aura une audition un peu plus
approfondie dans le cadre de notre
mission d'information j'en doute pas
mais quand même j'aimerais savoir si
l'enjeu de cette départementalisation de
la police et notamment sur le volet
judiciaire c'est pour vous d'atteindre
l'objectif des plus 50% d'effectif sur
le terrain un instant T qui vont
d'ailleurs faire des interpellations et
renouir de dossiers la police qui va
re-en-gorger la police judiciaire des
facto et le petit judiciaire avec ce
rapport de la Cour des comptes que vous
avez cité tout à l'heure 18 novembre
2021 qui constatait une diminution du
taux de lucidations et de la présence
sur le terrain alors qu'il y a une
augmentation de 20% des effectifs en
disant donc comme quoi il faut peut-être
regarder ça d'un peu plus près avant de
se lancer dans le même mur où est-ce que
l'objectif c'est juste d'avoir au mépris
de la séparation des pouvoirs un petit
peu plus la mamie sur les enquêtes et le
nombre d'enquêteurs qu'on met dans les
enquêtes parce que ce n'est pas vrai que
ce sont les magistrats qui choisissent
exactement leurs enquêteurs et l'ombre
d'enquêteurs bien souvent les chefs
disent que non ils sont déjà pris sur
telle affaire ou déjà occupés sur telle
chose ou telle commande préfet
puisqu'ils seront sous la coupe du
préfet merci Monsieur Ballan
sur l'effectivité des pouvoirs de police
des mers
vous le savez les dans de petites
communes les mers se sentent désunus des
unes pardon démunis face aux incivilités
qui n'arrivent pas à faire cesser ils se
sentent parfois abandonné par les
services de l'État le code général des
collectivités territoriales disposent
que le maire est chargé d'assurer le bon
ordre la sécurité la sûreté pardon la
sûreté la sécurité et la salubrité
publique et à ce titre il doit prévenir
et sanctionner certaines incivilités
ainsi qu'un ensemble de nuisances
pouvant éventuellement engendrer un
trouble anormal à la tranquillité
publique mais force cette constater que
ces prérogatives sont difficiles à
mettre en oeuvre dans les petites
communes
alors les mers n'ont pas les moyens
techniques humains et financiers pour
remplir pleinement ses missions
ils leur font un soutien administratif
qui me semble indispensable alors
peut-on imaginer une procédure
d'accompagnement fiable et automatique
des services compétents ils ont besoin
d'être concrètement aidés les maires par
le parquet la gendarmerie lorsque les
mesures qui sont prises ne sont pas
respectées alors Monsieur le Ministre
comment envisagez-vous de répondre à
cette attente forte légitime des mères
de petites communes est-ce que la loi de
finances pour 2023 permettra notamment
de leur apporter un soutien opérationnel
merci Monsieur bellanant monsieur pouya
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre je voudrais revenir très
rapidement sur la question des incendies
vous savez la Gironde a été dire bon
frappé et je tiens d'ailleurs à vous
remercier pour vos différentes venus en
Gironde qui ont été appréciés et qui
nous ont permis de rendre hommage à nos
pompiers DFCI et autres bénévoles
juste vous dire est-ce qu'il est
vraiment absolument impossible ou
inconcevable que la Gironde puisse
disposer d'une base de pour les moyens
aériens même j'ai envie de dire
temporaire car cela répondrait vraiment
à un besoin qui a été durement ressenti
et même si j'ai bien entendu vos propos
concernant la base
de Aix-en-Provence je pense que il
serait utile
d'y revenir merci pour la correction
un autre point que j'ai pu relever la
question des réservistes polices et
gendarmerie qui participent aussi au feu
et qui demandent à avoir un petit peu
plus de disponibilité en plus
sapeurs-pompiers volontaires et enfin
est-ce que le rapport prévu pour janvier
2023 sur le financement des 10 et bien
en finalisation d'écriture merci
Madame lelouis
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre
pardon je vais être très courte parce
que je ne peux pas condenser ma question
monsieur le ministre je vous l'enverrai
après la réponse merci
merci monsieur Rambaud
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre
face à cette réforme des services de la
police qui est en cours
d'expérimentation dans plusieurs
départements hexagonaux et d'outre-mer
les échos qui me sont parvenus ne sont
pas bons c'est le moins qu'on puisse
dire
ce projet de réforme visant à placer
tous les services y compris ceux de la
police judiciaire sous les ordres d'un
directeur départemental unique dépendant
du préfet inquiète les policiers mais
aussi les professionnels de justice
magistrats et avocat la suppression des
brigades spécialisées et la refonte dans
les effectifs globaux de la sécurité
publique des moyens des services
d'enquête et ressenti comme une
aberration or il est connu que les
enquêtes sur les dossiers les plus
lourds nécessitent plus de temps et de
moyens matériels et humains dans ces
circonstances
ne serait-il pas sage monsieur le
ministre de suspendre
l'expérimentation en cours et
d'abandonner purement et simplement
votre projet de création de direction
départementale de la police nationale
regroupant sous un commandement unique
l'ensemble des services de police merci
monsieur le ministre pour votre réponse
madame Martin qui est en visio
merci monsieur le Président bonjour à
tous on doit donc condenser notre propos
simplement en quelques mots monsieur le
ministre de l'Intérieur vous avez
considérablement changé la doctrine
française en matière de maintien de
l'ordre
particulièrement pour ce qui concerne la
tenue des manifestations étant entendu
que le maintien de l'ordre dans ce
contexte doit garantir la liberté de
manifester et ce en toute l'étude vous
l'avez donc changé de deux manières qui
sont deux aspects qui sont très
sensibles le premier par le fait d'aller
au contact et le second par la
déprofessionnalisation en ayant recours
à d'autres types de services de police
que les CRS est en particulier je pense
au service de bac il me semble que c'est
pour ces deux raisons là parce qu'il
faut aller vite que nous avons vu la
violence considérablement augmenter et
ceux d'une certaine façon d'ailleurs des
deux côtés quel bilan tirez-vous de cela
j'ai vu que dans la loi vous évoquiez
des aspects concernant le maintien de
l'ordre quel bilan tirez-vous de ces
deux changements encore une fois
sensibles dans la doctrine de maintien
de l'ordre en France et comment vous
projetez vous dans l'avenir pour à la
fois garantir évidemment le droit de
manifester en n'étant pas le confronté à
ces débordements de violents
monsieur le ministre nous avons évoqué
Nîmes tout à l'heure et vous avez repris
monsieur le ministre la comparaison des
chiffres de 2007 et ceux de 2012 pardon
ceux de 2017 pardon et de 2022 voilà on
va y arriver
j'ai pu le constater dans la
circonscription ou
à Bolbec nous sommes revenus par exemple
à des effectifs qui étaient ceux de 2017
en effet
cependant les commissariats qui n'aurait
pas eu les effectifs suffisants avant
2017 sont aussi évidemment un sujet et
là je prends l'exemple de Fécamp par
exemple pour ne pas le citer mais je
sais qu'il y a d'autres communes qui
sont concernées
est-ce qu'il y aura une autre doctrine
dans la répartition des effectifs pour
ces communes qui avaient vu leurs
effectifs baisser entre 2012 et 2017
notamment puisque ce n'était pas une
spécificité du précédent quinquennat
merci Monsieur le Ministre merci
Monsieur pont
merci monsieur le Président merci
Monsieur le Ministre déjà de vos
nombreuses réponses la première question
c'est sur les CRS mns qui surveillent
nos plages avec compétences et surtout
autorité est-ce que les communes peuvent
imaginer avoir toujours ses effectifs
dans les années à venir et
éventuellement ce qui les ont perdu
peuvent-elles espérer d'en récupérer la
deuxième question c'est déjà un peu
répondu c'est sur l'immigrants migrants
qui veulent à tout prix traverser le
channel qui se trouve sur nos côtes à
qui on offre de l'hébergement mais qui
n'y restent qu'une qu'une nuit parce
qu'ils veulent comme vous l'avez dit à
tout prix traverser est-ce qu'on peut
imaginer qu'un nouveau traité puisse
permettre un certain nombre de brigands
et quand je dis un certain nombre il est
pas il est peut-être conséquent de
pouvoir se rendre en Grande-Bretagne
sans risque je vous remercie
merci alors pardon j'ai perdu le fil
madame rouleau
c'est bon oui oui monsieur le ministre
je souhaitais vous interroger sur un
problème pratique la difficulté de
porter plainte problème d'autant plus
préoccupant lorsqu'il s'agit de victimes
de violence et notamment de violences
conjugales qui a défaut d'être recueilli
et transmise à temps peuvent dépuches
déboucher sur de véritables drames
l'article
15-3 du code de procédure pénale indique
la police judiciaire est tenue de
recevoir les plaintes déposées par la
victime or ce n'est pas toujours ce
qu'il se passe en pratique les victimes
se trouvant trop souvent et conduites
faute de preuves accompagnant leur
plainte on leur conseille dans ce cas de
déposer une main courante qui n'aura
évidemment pas la même portée juridique
et qui sera surtout
ignoré du parquet
autorité à même elle 2 poursuivre ceci
pose un véritable problème
or pourquoi cela se passe ainsi je me
dépêche parce que je vois
le compteur est éclos alors sauf si
monsieur le Président m'accorde
m'accordent quoi
allez alors c'est tout simple c'est
parce qu'en fait les policiers savent
très bien qu'une plainte sans preuve
sera à de fortes chances d'être classé
donc ils ont pas envie de perdre du
temps pour rien on les comprend tout à
fait et donc ma question mais vous avez
déjà répondu est-ce qu'il y aura plus de
policiers vous m'avez dit oui est-ce
qu'il y aura des des plaintes en ligne
vous avez également dit qu'on pourrait
poser déposer plainte posé plein de
tendines mais actuellement c'est réservé
qu'à certaines plaintes et c'est pas du
tout facile donc j'espère vraiment que
ça pourra recouvrir toutes les plaintes
et dernière question est-ce que dans une
circulaire est-ce que dans une
circulaire vous j'en ai jamais posé
c'est ma première dans une circulaire
est-ce que vous pourrez rappeler aux
policiers qu'en fait c'est le parquet
qui a l'opportunité de poursuite et eux
il faut qu'il recueille même semble même
sans preuve c'est une première question
donc ça nécessite mon agenda
c'est pas votre première question c'est
cool
pardon monsieur le ministre nous avons
appris l'existence d'un déploiement
d'une patrouille de gendarmerie mixte
franco-italienne en Val dessusz du côté
italien des Alpes envis de la vallée de
la Maurienne le protocole opérationnel
des deux forces de l'ordre a été signé à
Turin par le commandant de l'armée
italienne
ces manœuvres sont décrites comme
non-concurrentes à celle de la police
des frontières mais coordonnée à partir
du centre de commandement basé à Modane
mon question sont donc les suivantes
quel motif justifie de mobiliser nos
gendarmes sur des opérations
extraterritoriales quant au même moment
ils sont un effectif insuffisant dans
nos zones rurales et périurbaines pour
pouvoir exercer leur mission de sécurité
auprès des Françaises et des Français et
la deuxième question la zone de
déploiement de nos gendarmes se
superpose à la zone de chantier de la
ligne ferroviaire controversiée du lion
Turin au regard du non-respect par
l'exploitant de ce chantier des DUP sur
l'eau les militaires italiens seront-ils
associés à nos gendarmes français pour
faire respecter la loi française et
faire CC les excavations illégales des
tunneliers en Maurienne merci Monsieur
Manon
merci monsieur le président
je voudrais revenir sur les moyens de
réprimer les rodéo sauvages nous avons
monsieur le ministre indiqué que vous en
faites une priorité de votre action et
nous tenons à vous en remercier le
phénomène est hélas pas nouveau mes
reconnaissons qu'il a pu prendre
notamment cet été
une dimension
forte et que le phénomène s'est amplifié
vous nous savons que la loi a apporté un
être durcissement de la réponse pénale à
partir de 2018
mais aujourd'hui il nous faut dépasser
le stade de l'évaluation ou du constat
et donner des moyens d'agir aux forces
de l'ordre alors au titre des
propositions qui ont pu être évoquées on
parle d'une expérimentation de la
méthode d'interception britannique
dite de contact tactique c'est
d'ailleurs réclamé par un certain nombre
de syndicats de police alors par rapport
à cette mesure est-ce que monsieur le
ministre vous pourriez nous indiquer
votre sentiment merci Monsieur terrier
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre merci permettez-moi en propos
liminaire de m'étonner qui n'est pas une
illimité autour de cette loi
d'orientation et de programmation du
ministère de l'Intérieur tant les
crédits qui sont alloués à l'instar de
ce qu'on a pu voter lors du précédent au
niveau des militaires mettre 15
milliards d'euros pour nos forces de
l'ordre des sécurités mais aussi
également la création de 8500 postes et
c'est d'autant plus j'allais dire un
grand franc succès et je crois qu'il
faut s'en féliciter que ça la vient
après des un renforcement considérable
de nos moyens lors de voter lors du
précédent quinquennat qui ont permis
notamment à Castres dans ma
circonscription le retour et de la
création de la brigade anti criminalité
pour laquelle je vous invite à venir au
mois de septembre ou au mois de au mois
de novembre pour pour évidemment
l'inaugurer ma question porte sur la
Loize l'immigration vous avez parlé
évidemment de ce qu'il était prévu en
termes de planification par contre
du contour de la simplification de la
procédure j'aimerais savoir s'il était
possible que vous puissiez nous en
donner quelques contours on le sait
cette loi de procédure peine parce qu'il
y a deux procédures qui sont juxtaposées
l'une relative à la question de locuteur
et l'autre relative à l'appréciation de
la du fait que les les personnes
puissent bénéficier ou pas d'un titre de
séjour et du droit d'asile et donc
j'aurais aimé savoir si vous pouviez
nous apporter quelques précisions merci
madame Diaz
oui c'est le ministre vous avez passé
beaucoup de temps à faire de grandes
annonces sur le projet de loi Asie
l'immigration on peut supposer que ces
agitations n'avaient qu'un seul but
redorer votre image suite au fiasco du
Stade de France et suite au fâcheuses
épisodes de l'imam radical j'aurai une
petite question au passage mais où est
donc passé Hassan ikwissen et finalement
patatra Emmanuel Macron détruit
littéralement votre opération de
communication en révélant le réel
objectif de cette loi transformer nos
campagnes en dortoir à clandestin au cas
où vous l'auriez oublié je vous rappelle
que cette Français sur dix souhaite
mettre un terme à la submersion
migratoire et que Marine Le Pen est
arrivé en tête au second tour de
l'élection présidentielle dans plus de
18000 communes par conséquent allez-vous
écouter les revendications des Français
qui ne vous demandent pas de répartir
les migrants mais qui vous demandent de
les faire repartir
s de la Bastille avec des dizaines de
jeunes qui n'ont pas été reconnus comme
des mineurs non accompagnés le recours
pour contester une décision de ne pas
être connue comme une étant pas
suspensif déjà ne se retrouvent livrés à
eux-mêmes et la précarité la
vulnérabilité dans lesquelles il se
trouve pour conséquence de faire
basculer certains dans la délinquance
aussi comme aucune prise en charge n'est
prévue durant cette période de recours
alors qu'ils sont nombreux à être
finalement reconnus mineurs par le juge
des enfants je souhaitais savoir si vous
envisagez des solutions pour garantir ce
premier accueil de ce qui arrive sur
notre territoire pour déterminer dès le
départ très clairement et rapidement
leur situation administrative pour
éviter ainsi les risques de dérive et
les délais d'instruction des dossiers
qui vont faire perdurer cette présence
de campement dans nos rues et afin
également de garantir la dignité la
sécurité l'intégration de ces jeunes
dans notre société je vous remercie
merci monsieur kerbra
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre j'ai visité mercredi dernier le
centre de rétention administrative de
Vincennes avec des collègues
parlementaires et le Syndicat des
Avocats de France les fondations les
conditions de cette rétention qui
ressemblent plus à une détention sont
déplorable les personnes placées ainsi
que les policiers se plaignent des
conditions de rétention oui on y perd la
liberté au même temps que ça divinité et
aux yeux de la Cour européenne des
droits de l'homme nous sommes des
multivistes de la maltraitance et du
déshonneur pire dans ce sens de
rétention se trouve un Guinéen arrivé en
France mineur porteur du VIH il y est
depuis février 2022 le médecin de l'OFI
prétend qu'il peut se faire soigner en
Guinée alors que seulement un quart des
Guinéens peuvent accéder au traitement
et que l'arrêté 2017 du ministère de la
Santé protège les étrangers séropositifs
j'aurais préféré vous demander quand
vous alliez fermer les centres de
rétention mais c'est pas votre projet je
vous pose donc deux questions
qu'avez-vous prévu pour améliorer
améliorer les conditions de rétention
pour les étrangers mais aussi les
conditions de travail des agents dans
ces centres et quelles réponses
allez-vous apporter à ses étrangers
malades à part votre indifférence et
votre course populiste derrière
l'extrême droite
et le dernier orateur monsieur housse
monsieur le ministre depuis des années
le taux d'étrangers contre lesquels la
France prononce une auqtf c'est à dire
une obligation de quitter le territoire
français et qui le quitte réellement et
ridicule il était déjà inférieur à 20%
sous François Hollande et votre
gouvernement semblait conscient du
problème puisque monsieur Macron et
vous-même affirmiez vouloir atteindre
100% de qtf effective malheureusement
pour les années 2020 et 2021 les
résultats sont là on est à environ 7%
d'eau qtf effective ce qui veut dire que
93% de ces personnes restent sur notre
territoire or nos journaux nos tribunaux
regorgent de centaines de cas
d'agresseurs de violeurs de criminels
qui récidivent en France alors même qui
sont sous le coup d'une occupef et
qu'ils auraient déjà dû quitter le pays
ce qui pose plusieurs questions combien
de victimes supplémentaires sont dues à
vos mauvais résultats en matière de qtf
et surtout quels moyens nouveau
comptez-vous mettre en place pour
améliorer ces chiffres et en particulier
pour expulser tous les délinquants déjà
condamnés et qui le coût d'une auqtf
merci à tous me rend compte que vous
débrouillez tous très bien en une minute
donc ça me donne des idées monsieur le
ministre pour la conclusion de cette
audition merci peut-être commencer par
Monsieur le Député vous voyez monsieur
le député on peut être d'accord sur un
certain nombre de points mais alors
votre présentation est non seulement
caricaturale mais absolument mensongère
vous avez pris
vous avez pris l'exemple de 2020 2021 et
sauf que c'était des années covid ah
vous voyez c'est assez normal qu'on
puisse pas recouvrir des gens aux
frontières quand les gens quand il y a
plus d'avion quand il y a plus d'avion
c'est assez difficile à courir des gens
frontières et surtout quand les
personnes ne peuvent pas quitter le
territoire parce que il y a un certain
temps d'assignation du fait de la lutte
contre la pandémie c'est dommage que
vous n'ayez pas pris c'est dommage que
n'aie pas pris l'exemple du calcana
parce que vous auriez vu que nous étions
à plus de 30% avant l'année covid de
2020 qui était le lundi du discours du
président de la République donc si vous
aviez un minimum d'honnêteté
intellectuel vous pourriez dire que bien
sûr on pourrait atteindre 100% de qtf
que c'est le but évidemment de tout
arrêter de reconduite à la frontière je
partage cette opinion mais prendre des
années où on ne pouvait pas excuser de
personnes que vous allez de référence
d'un discours du président de la
République qu'il avait tenu quelques
semaines avant le début de la pandémie
je trouve que ça montre que vous ne
cherchez pas la vérité mais vous
cherchez des problèmes parce que grâce à
ces problèmes vous êtes élus
manifestement vous êtes un peu trop vite
démasqué essayez peut-être la prochaine
fois de maquiller le cadavre de façon
plus efficace pour vous monsieur le
député moi j'entends votre question sur
notamment par exemple que vous avez pris
de ce ressortissant guinéen ce que vous
n'avez pas plus dit non plus c'est que
ce monsieur est passé en rétention
depuis le 15 août 2022 il a déjà eu lui
trois auqtf depuis 2018 il se trouve que
ce monsieur est consommateur et
comment dirais-je de l'heure de crack
qu'il a eu 11 antécédents au casier
judiciaire pour viol sur majeur à
plusieurs reprises et sur séquestration
donc il y a un médecin dont je ne
commande pas évidemment les commandes
médicales et effectivement ce monsieur
qui n'est pas légalement sur le
territoire national qui a commis des
crimes
ignobles que vous n'avez pas précisé
dans votre intervention là aussi je
trouve que c'est un peu dommage de pas
avoir fait une présentation un peu de
présentation un peu biaisée faisons
croire que nous n'avions pas d'humanité
et qui par ailleurs et qui par ailleurs
monsieur par ailleurs monsieur le juge
de liberté de la détention et le médecin
de personnes pour lequel ils intérieurs
entre nous assez peu de pouvoir sur eux
redonner un avis d'expulsion favorable
donc je pense encore une fois que c'est
très intéressant cette présentation du
rassemblement national et de votre
groupe la France insoumise montre que si
on peut être d'accord sur le principe
sur votre présentation que les gens qui
soient soignés on a 4000 en France qui
sont soignés chaque année au nom du
ministère de l'Intérieur vous
m'interrogez pas sur eux et notamment
les personnes séropositives et personne
qui considère notamment des personnes
qui ont expulser parce qu'ils sont des
vacances je regrette que le débat
parlementaire est politique se fasse pas
sur des arguments de vérité parce que
vous essayez de mettre la confusion et
ça démontre bien je peux pas le projet
politique que vous portez c'est pas
celui d'une recherche de la vérité
d'efficacité mais bien simplement de
faire un coup politique et personne
personnellement je le regrette
profondément mais en deux en deux en
deux en deux présentations j'ai réussi à
démontrer monsieur le député pour une
question que vous m'avez pas passer en
avance avouez-le que vous avez la
manifestement essayer de détourner la
vérité et l'opinion et c'est vraiment
c'est scandale
madame madame
Abadie vous avez posé la question de la
cybercriminalité et sur ça et de Pharos
ce qui me permet de répondre en même
temps à la question qui m'a été posée
précédemment par la député sur la cyber
délinquance sur lequel j'ai pas pu
répondre et je m'en excuse
d'abord sur les moyens que nous y
mettons la question qui a été posée par
la députée avant la coupure était en
faisant l'assurance des rançons
logiciels et prenez l'exemple son Pinel
est-ce qu'on ne va pas encourager
finalement les rangs sont une sorte de
c'est un peu comme si vous disiez on va
pas assurer les cambriolages parce qu'on
va
multiplier du coup les cambriages on va
pas assurer les vols de véhicules parce
que il y aura moins de vols peut-être
pas assuré non plus les accidents de
voiture comme ça on voit bien que ce qui
se passe dans le monde Internet et la
délinquance que nous connaissons
appliquée aux normes numériques donc moi
je suis bien sûr pour faire attention et
c'est parce que les mises économies et
des finances il n'a pas donné une assu
une autorisation d'assurance pour que
les gens puissent répondre au chantage
mais nous du coup nous constatons
malheureusement que beaucoup
d'entreprises beaucoup d'établissements
publics même beaucoup de particuliers ne
portent même pas plainte et personne
parfois eux régler la rançon ou payer
d'autres
officines pour pouvoir combattre ces
cyberattaque c'est pas comme ça qu'on
luttera contre cette délinquance qui est
de plus en plus importante que celle
donc je veux dire qu'avec Bercy nous y
travaillons bien sûr le volet du
ministère intérieur est très important
puisqu'il le vise à la prévention et il
vise à aux enquêtes et nous allons
augmenter de 1500 agents en 5 ans c'est
dans la luth me les cyber patrouilleurs
soit des personnes qui vont dans des
sites comme Pharos j'y reviendrai soit
des gens qui sont dans des services
d'enquête et qui luttent contre la cyber
des vacances je rappelle que plus de la
moitié déjà de nos concitoyens des
concitoyens de vos circonscriptions sont
victimes de cyber délinquance sont une
escroquerie 50% d'aide et un camp
financières d'escroquerie est déjà tout
je te concitoyens y compris les
personnes âgées qui parfois ne
comprennent pas pourquoi ils reçoivent
un mail qui s'est passé pour quelqu'un
d'autre par exemple qui utilise son mot
de passe ou ses numéros de compte
bancaire donc c'est vraiment un point
très très important
de lutter extrêmement fortement pour que
la cyber voiture du policier du gendarme
soit aussi rapide efficace que la cyber
voiture du du délinquant
alors si je peux pas 54 enquêteurs qui
sont
farose donc on a doublé le nombre
d'agents qui avaient à Pharos et qui
désormais travaillent 24 heures sur 24
ça joue 7 jours sur 7 contrairement à ce
qu'on pense mais vous l'avez dit en
partie farose bien sûr ça dénonce les
contenus terroristes mais ça dépend
surtout les attentes de mineurs et
aujourd'hui le premier signalement des
personnes sur farose Internet c'est les
atteintes au mineur j'aurai l'occasion
d'ailleurs d'y revenir pour augmenter
avec ma collègue Charlotte cobel le
nombre d'enquêteurs qui sont auprès des
des personnes qui luttent contre la
pédophilie les viols en ligne
malheureusement de plus en plus nombreux
sur le Dark web et dont les les
policiers de gendarmes doivent être
particulièrement renforcés en lien avec
le ministère de la Justice sur ces sur
ces enquêtes on a eu 263 825 signalement
reçu sur sur farose et donc vous l'avez
compris nous continuerons à augmenter le
contenu en homme et en femme en
enquêteur de manière générale là aussi
avec d'ailleurs un site qui va se
délocaliser de Nanterre à Lens puisque
nous avons décidé de pouvoir
déconcentrer un certain nombre de
services du ministère et donc les agents
de pharoses iront dans le joli
département du Pas-de-Calais
je veux dire que sur la question de ce
Guitton sur le secteur agricole il a
raison il y a une augmentation de
délinquance forte autour du monde
agricole et du monde viticole vous
l'avez particulièrement dit nos
agriculteurs sont particulièrement
touchées leur vol de bétail leur vol de
matériel
comme souvent ils habitent là où ils ont
leur exploitation évidemment c'est une
violation de domicile alors ils le sont
par un certain nombre de délinquants
mais ils le sont aussi par des
associations qu'on peut qualifier
d'extrémistes qui viennent les empêcher
d'avoir un fonctionnement normal de leur
de leurs exploitations on a mis en place
et sa date d'il y a un certain temps
déjà le travail de Déméter qui
malheureusement a été contestée par la
jurisprudence administrative nous avons
confirmé la présence de Déméter auprès
notamment aux organisations
professionnelles agricoles et viticoles
c'est en gros les gendarmes qui
travaillent toute particulièrement
auprès des exploitations agricoles et
nous avons vous avez entendu augmenter
jusqu'à 1500 gendarmes verts
c'est-à-dire des gendarmes spécialisés
dans l'hyper ruralité eu en lien avec le
monde agricole les deux manières
générales les exploitants de la nature
pour lutter contre toutes formes
d'attente environnementale c'est sûr
mais aussi d'atteinte de délinquance
dans les 200 brigades nous allons
effectivement renforcer particulièrement
les lieux qui ne connaissent pas ou
assez loin des brigades de gendarmerie
depuis 20 ans on a supprimé 500 brigades
de gendarmerie avant l'arrivée du
président de la République Emmanuel
Macron on en recréé 200 c'est la
première fois depuis 20 ans qu'on recrée
des brigades de gendarmerie donc comme
je vous l'ai dit vous serez tous invité
dans vos départements par les parler
préfets pas vos commandants de
groupement avec l'ensemble des élus pour
décider quels sont les implantations et
en février je rendrai évidemment ma
décision même les communes qui ne
connaîtront pas de brigade de
gendarmerie vont en fait un renforcement
d'effectif puisque là où on met une
brigade évidemment ça permet à l'autre
brigade de faire moins de kilomètres
pour venir intervenir dans tel ou tel
endroit mais vous avez parfaitement
raison sur la protection que l'on doit à
nos agriculteurs et nos viticulteurs
puisque vous avez parlé d'eux en
particulier je vais répondre à Monsieur
bernalicis je comprends que de là où il
est il nous entend c'est à dire sans
doute en numérique que je veux je
m'inscrire en faux sur son constat en
tout cas sur sa question non j'ai
compris qu'elle n'était pas fines mais
qu'elle était le souci de sa part de
mieux comprendre ce que nous essayons de
faire et ainsi je permettrais d'en
parler également à Monsieur rabot c'est
ça pardon
Rambo pardon qui m'a appelé sur la même
sur la même réforme tout ce que vous
avez dit tous les deux sur les
propositions indépendamment du fait que
vous soyez ou pas pour cette réforme et
il faut il n'y a pas de suppression de
brigade de spécialisée monsieur député
il n'y a pas de suppression d'office il
n'y a pas de suppression de brigades
spécialisée il y aura toujours le sera
toujours donc je sais que on a vu cette
fake news de circuler je veux vous
redire ici devant les parlementaires de
la nation que la réforme de la police
nationale ne vient pas supprimer des
offices ou des brigades spécialisées le
deuxième sujet on peut être contre pour
d'autres raisons que que celle-là en
tout cas ça ça n'existe pas la même
raison c'est je veux dire non la réforme
de la police nationale et notamment la
forme de la police judiciaire ne vise
pas à augmenter les heures de patrouille
sur la voie publique pour ceux qui ne
l'ont pas suivi le président de la
République dans son discours de Roubaix
après le bobo la sécurité a donné comme
objectif au ministère d'intérieur
soi-disant de doubler le nombre de
patrouilles sur la voie publique je
pourrais démontrer à l'envie peut-être
lors d'un autre pays d'audition sur la
queue de du texte de loi comment on y
arrive on y arrive par la fin de
certains cycles horaire on y arrive par
les réservistes de prix stationnaires
qu'on a créé par l'augmentation des
crédit réserves de la gendarmerie on y
arrive à l'augmentation des effectifs
mais on arrive en aucun cas il n'y a pas
une heure de travail qui est compté
comme étant la réforme de la Belgique
permet de mettre une personne sur la
voie publique c'est pas du tout l'objet
de intéressant donc je le redis non ça
ne fait pas partie des augmentations de
présence sur sur la voie publique donc
vraiment on aura l'occasion d'en
reparler avec Monsieur bernalicis c'est
peut-être avec vous monsieur monsieur
robot moi je veux redire que par
ailleurs j'ai du mal à comprendre
comment on évoque à chaque fois des taux
d'hélicitations une police qui doit être
plus performante et refuser les moyens
de modernité il s'agit de refaire de
refaire la modernité de la police c'est
normal elle a pas bougé depuis un
certain temps malgré ses évolutions et
malgré ces personnel et sur la police
judiciaire on la renforce et évidemment
on change un certain nombre d'habitudes
qui sont toujours difficiles et je veux
dire à Monsieur Bernard ici ce qu'il ne
s'agit pas de la réforme de la
départementalisation de la police c'est
un bout de la réforme c'est la réforme
de la police nationale au sens large
mais avec des conséquences territoriales
qui ne sont pas
des conséquences seulement locales
alors sur la l'accompagnement des maires
se baladins
je suis un peu embêté parce que je
comprends ce que vous dites et je le
soutiens mais mais ça relève pas
stricto-sensuit du ministre italien
parce que quand les maires constatent
des choses en tant que pays ça relève de
la justice voilà et d'ailleurs quand ils
font des actes d'état civil et de
contestation d'état civil ça enlève
aussi vous savez bien de la justice
alors on pourrait y mettre davantage de
moyens à l'écoute notamment parce que
parler des maires de petites communes
auprès de la gendarmerie on a cette
façon de choses mais je vais réfléchir
peut-être avec vous à ce qu'on pourrait
faire de mieux dans l'accompagnement il
y a des formations désormais qui sont
faits par les commandants de groupement
dans chacun des départements de France à
ma demande puisque c'était la demande
des maires de l'Association des mers
ruraux donc désormais chaque année
plusieurs fois par an les gendarmes
viennent former les élus municipaux
c'est quoi leur pouvoir de PJ bon voilà
donc ça c'est je pense quelque chose de
positif mais je crois que votre question
dépend plus peut-être de Monsieur mise à
justice mais je veux bien la relier
bienvenue notamment monsieur Pouillard
sur les sur les feux de des feux de
la question des implantations bon et et
compliqué je défends l'implantation
unique de Nîmes pour l'instant parce
qu'on n'a pas à trouver les moyens de
permettre d'avoir une deuxième équipe
qui fasse que je vous ai dit c'est à
dire que quand le Canada se pose il faut
le réparer la nuit sinon on va voir
moins de roulement sur nos appareils si
nous devions agrandir notre faute de
façon considérable la question de
deuxième base pourrait se poser mais
c'est forcément des financements
européens vu le montant que ça nous
coûte en revanche il y a des pélican
dromes et vous en avez dans votre
département c'est à dire des petites des
petits avions pardon avec une petite
réserve d'eau qui permet justement de
faire ce que j'évoquais de pouvoir
intervenir très vite sur un feu pour
l'éteindre très vite puisque 90% des
feux sont éteints quasiment lorsqu'ils
ont même pas atteint cinq hectares et la
lune des difficultés c'est quand le feu
prend trop d'importance c'est pour ça
que vous voyez que quand tu as des
grands feux parfois les les avions s'en
vont du feu pour aller ailleurs alors
les élus disent mais pourquoi ils s'en
vont bah ils s'en vont parce que quand
le feu est très grand on ne peut pas
l'arrêter avec quelques avions alors
qu'on peut arrêter le fen à quelques
kilomètres plus loin bon donc il y a
sans doute de manière générale à revoir
notre système de sécurité civile mais je
veux pas vous répondre trop facilement
sur sur la base bien sûr en Gironde en
revanche on a remarqué puisqu'on parle
de votre département que il y avait au
moment de la déclaration des feux et
l'attaque des pompiers les feux le 10
n'avait pas monopolisé l'intégralité des
agents de sapeurs-pompiers donc il y a
aussi aussi du côté des 10 peut-être à
mobiliser l'ensemble des
sapeurs-pompiers sur leur sujet
d'ailleurs moi je pense que ça serait
intéressant lorsqu'on discutera de
sécurité civile que pour les réservistes
policiers gendarmes et pompiers on
puisse trouver rendre obligatoire que
l'employeur parfois public parfois
public c'est pas lequel on peut en privé
libère les personnes un peu comme l'élu
à un statut et qui doit être libéré pour
son conseil municipal donc voilà je
pense que c'est une disposition qui sera
intéressante à imposer dans un texte de
loi quand on y réfléchira
et le rapport se financement oui l'iggia
enfin moi me le rend je crois dans deux
mois donc il sera si jamais la
Commission le souhaite évidemment à sa
disposition
alors j'ai eu des questions sur les
effectifs de police à fécan mais pas
café quand grand port de pêche qui
entendent rester
bon aujourd'hui il y a 39 policiers
africains il y avait 35 en 2017 bon donc
ça augmente la fécan et je comprends la
question de la député exmère que moi je
prends le moment où on est arrivé en
responsabilité bien évidemment mais on
peut imaginer qu'il y en avait plus
avant avant c'était peut-être même pas
les mêmes les mêmes circonscriptions de
police madame la députée ou la
délinquance a changé parce que des
projets urbains d'augmentation de
population de ligne de transport la
question que je pose notamment
d'augmentation de la délinquance dans
les transports c'est que comme les
métropoles ont grandi parfois les lignes
de transport qui sont l'un des objets
des vecteurs de la délinquance les plus
importantes va désormais sur deux zones
une zone police une zone gendarmerie par
exemple de Toulouse qui prend 10 000
habitants par an et du coup là où
auparavant les transports étaient
quasiment gérés par la police désormais
il y a une coordination plus
intelligente à faire l'entreprise et
gendarmerie sur la même ligne de
transport donc oui vous avez raison il y
a eu des évolutions aussi
institutionnelles qui font que la
comparaison 2017 et forcément une mesure
et comme d'autres mesures discutable
alors les effectifs que nous allons
créer de toute façon supplémentaire vont
désormais aller en surplus du chiffre de
2017 puisque à l'heure où je vous parle
l'intégralité des commissariats de
France a vu une effective supérieure en
2022 par rapport à 2017 donc on a tenu
notre promesse si j'ose dire de 2017 la
difficulté que nous avons aujourd'hui
c'est que nous devons soit renforcer des
effectifs dans certains endroits pour
combler par rapport au chiffre de la
délinquance qui mériterait d'avoir plus
d'effectif de police soit de bloquer les
départs ce que j'ai expliqué tout à
l'heure quand même un député que le
ministre de l'intérieur était limité
dans les affectations de policiers mais
le ministre il est aussi limité puisque
il peut mettre sans policier de plus à
Marseille si on a c'est la question que
vous me posiez sur le net ou le ou le
Panet tout à l'heure sur Nîmes si on a
beaucoup plus qui partent dans ces cas
là alors vous savez que les ministres
précédents ont bloqué à la préfecture de
police un contrat de 8 ans quand vous
êtes muté à Paris petite couronne vous
pouvez pas faire plus de 8 ans au moins
sur un territoire particulier ça a des
avantages et des inconvénients de cette
situation moi je vais proposer par un
décret évidemment après avoir consulté
les syndicats de police que nous
puissions mettre à pourcentage de départ
dans chaque commissariat parce que il
faut bien voir que quand on crée des
effectifs de police on les met pour
lutter contre une certaine délinquance
et c'est normal que ça tombe de
policiers souhaite quitter ses zones qui
sont pas toujours les plus agréables à
vivre pour plein de raisons d'ailleurs
pas que pour des raisons
professionnelles ça peut des raisons
personnelles parce que leur conjoint et
l'autre côté de la France par exemple et
donc ce qu'on va faire ce qui n'est pas
le cas aujourd'hui moi j'ai parfois j'ai
des parts de 15% dans un commissariat
nous allons limiter un pourcentage de
départ pour que à la fois quand on met
des effectifs on soit de façon certaine
capable de croire qu'il y a une
croissance et pas de dire mais à combien
qui partir en retraite qui partiront de
l'autre côté avec la zone atlantique
et plutôt très bien pourvu en policier
et que l'axe urbain Lille Lyon Marseille
pour faire très vite et plutôt moins
bien pourvu en policier il y a aussi un
peu de un peu d'aménagement de la
structure des affectation de policiers
c'est pas qu'une question d'effectif
c'est aussi une question de comment on
répartit ces effectifs c'est effectifs
de police
la question a été posée
sur les manifestations je vois madame
Martin sur l'écran donc je ne voulais
pas oublier de lui répondre donc sur
l'ordre public ils sont générale alors
c'est pas tellement moi qui ai changé
madame la députée la façon de faire
l'ordre public je rappelle notamment les
événements à Paris de préfet de police
qui sont succédés c'est je n'ai pas
l'honneur d'être mise de l'Intérieur à
ce moment-là mais je pense que ce qu'a
vécu la préfecture de police qui est en
général le lieu principal du maintien de
l'ordre quoi que on verra qu'il peut y
avoir d'autres situations bien
évidemment fait qu'il y a eu des
manifestations spontanées non déclarées
avec en France il faut déclarer les
manifestations
numériques on ne sait pas le nombre de
personnes qui venaient sans organisation
professionnelle quand la CGT organisée
de manifestation travaillait que les
services de police auparavant je dis pas
qu'elle avait pas de cases dans
certaines manifestations enfin il y
avait un service d'ordre qui était
organisé il y avait une discussion
indépendamment des difficultés
politiques entre les positions on voit
bien qu'aujourd'hui tout ça a changé
profondément et donc je crois que ce qui
s'est passé mais beaucoup de gens ont
écrit sur ce sujet j'ai même été
auditionné plusieurs fois c'est un
changement des manifestations
qu'on peut qualifier parfois de de
spontané et de difficilement maîtrisable
dans leur parcours et dans leur dans
leur fonctionnement alors il y a eu
beaucoup de modifications l'une des
difficultés quand même que nous avons
dans le public madame ça reste malgré
tout la mobilité de ces forces mobiles
et le nombre de forces mobiles
c'est-à-dire que moi l'ordre public je
veux je veux redire ici que c'est un
métier c'est pas la même chose c'est
d'être policier de sécurité publique que
d'être policier dans le public et ce qui
a pas bien fonctionné vous savez bien
dans les manifestations violentes des
gilets jaunes c'est qu'on a mis des
policiers de voie publique pas
simplement à Paris il peut aussi dans
des villes de province s'occuper de
l'ordre public et pour tout le monde
c'est difficile parce qu'ils n'ont pas
les techniques professionnelles d'ordre
public ils n'ont pas le matériel non
plus pour le faire et eux-mêmes ont été
parfois molestés ou attaqués parce que
c'est pas leur métier de faire cela donc
il fallait absolument augmenter en
nombre d'effectifs et peut-être que
voilà on a en parlait tout à l'heure des
500 brigades de gendarmerie qui avait
été supprimés il y a eu 15 escadron du
FM qui ont été supprimés dans les 20
dernières années donc faut aussi voir
Madame que quand la les manifestations
violentes ou en tout cas spontanées
originales différentes multipliées sont
arrivés c'est le moment sans doute les
forces de police étaient les moins
armées pour pouvoir faire face à ces
enjeux donc d'abord on a on a augmenté
et on continue à augmenter les forces
mobiles bien évidemment les 11 escadron
je l'évoquais ou les 7 qu'on va libérer
de Paris par ailleurs il y a une
question de mobilité on a beaucoup
travaillé sur ce qu'on appelle la
sécabilité comment les CRS et jardins ne
travaillent pas en groupe mais
travaillent par petit groupe et
également les mobilités par leur
matériel j'y reviendrai pas ensuite vous
avez raison le policier de gendarme il
est avant tout là pour que la
manifestation se déroule selon le droit
constitutionnel à manifester et moi je
me je suis très fier d'être mise à
l'intérieur d'un pays qui organise des
manifestations contre le ministre de
l'Intérieur et on les protège et on fait
des réunions pour que les choses se
passent le mieux possible les policiers
mais ils encadrent des personnes qui les
insultent et qui disent que la police
tue bon mais ils le font avec je crois
beaucoup de d'efficacité républicaines
donc vous avez totalement raison le
droit à manifester c'est un droit
constitutionnel que la police
gendarmerie doit permettre d'exprimer
quand il y a de la violence c'est tous
les gens qui veulent manifester
librement qui ne peuvent pas le faire
quelque soit leurs opinions politiques
donc ce point est évidemment essentiel
et je le répète à chaque fois que
j'évoque l'ordre public avec les
policiers gendarmes la deuxième des
choses madame c'est que la stratégie de
droit public n'a jamais n'avait jamais
été écrite alors ce que j'ai fait moi
c'est vrai c'est que je l'ai écrit j'ai
écrit un schéma national du matcha de
l'ordre le premier était retoqué par le
Conseil d'État donc je n'ai réécris un
deuxième qui a été accepté par le
Conseil d'État et par les professions de
journalistes c'est un point très
important et donc il prévoit un certain
nombre de choses il s'en doute pas
absolument parfait mais de meilleur
coordination entre les organisateurs
quels qu'ils soient et les préfectures
les journalistes qui doivent évidemment
être traités de façon privilégiée pour
pouvoir couvrir ces manifestations
que la nasse qui est une technique
d'intervention spécifique laisse
toujours une sortie dans une
manifestation donc évidemment toutes ces
choses moi j'ai pas eu la connaître de
très grands manifestations dans le
public depuis qu'on a écrit ce chemin du
match de Lord j'espère que la rentrée
sociale me permettra pas de les vivre
plus que celle-là mais ce qui est sûr
c'est que nous avons désormais des
effectifs des moyens technologiques et
un schéma qui est validé par le Conseil
d'État et
accompagné par les organisations
professionnelles de journalistes je
voudrais dire peut-être un point de
particulier c'est que pendant longtemps
le Parlement m'a refusé et a refusé mes
inter successifs les drones et les mêmes
qui reprochaient qui manifestations
étaient violentes refusé
à la police et la gendarmerie utilisait
les drones en gros en France tout le
monde peut faire voler un drone sauf les
policiers si je devais résumer la
situation dans laquelle nous étions
désormais la loi a permis à l'état mise
intérieur de faire voler des drones
renseignement et pas en judiciaire j'ai
du mal à comprendre ma femme se présente
cette décision parce que je ressembler
que judiciaire était plus protecteur des
libertés dans le discours public puisque
s'autorité d'un juge mais il a été jugé
que les préfets étaient plus protecteurs
de liberté d'ontact bon donc en
renseignement et donc les décrets vont
sortir dans quelques jours et
permettront aux policiers et aux
gendarmes de faire voler des drones dans
l'environnement ça surveillera la
délinquance et enseignement les points
de Deal et les drodéo aussi et ça aidera
à surveiller les manifestations en
renseignement donc il s'agit là non pas
de récupérer des informations pour
pouvoir judiciariser mais de pouvoir
reculer des informations pour permettre
de voir où sont les manifestations où
est-ce qu'il faut placer les forces et
comment comment on le fait moi je
regrette que la PPL rotaïo ait été
censurée à l'époque ça nous aurait
permis de pouvoir faire ce que nous
faisons un terrorisme c'est à dire
d'éviter que des gens se baladent avec
des marteaux en manifestations on peut
manifester je suis pas sûr que un
marteau par exemple soit absolument
indispensable pour pour manifester enfin
on aura sans doute l'occasion dans dans
reparler
je crois que alors les brigades sont
italiens je voudrais pas ne pas vous
répondre bon elle est effectivement le
traité un traité international c'est peu
d'effectif c'est à la fois dans la lutte
contre des vacances contre l'immigration
illégale mais aussi contre les objets
importants de l'amour franco-italien que
sont le projet d'infrastructure que vous
connaissez moi je m'inscris en faut il y
a pas de baisse d'effectif dans votre
département de gendarmes il y a une
augmentation et sans doute que les deux
brigades supplémentaires vont les
contribuer mais des brigades
franco-italienne ou
franco-espagnol on en a pour toute sorte
de raisons et notamment à frontière
italienne on en a avec nos amis italiens
sur la frontière la lutte immigration
illégale j'attire votre attention que
notamment autour de Modane il se trouve
que j'étais mise des contenus à ce
moment-là on avait un sujet c'est pour
ça qu'on a créé ces brigades
franco-italienne parce que rappelez-vous
les douaniers c'était pas arrêté à la
bonne station de train lorsqu'il faisait
des contrôles dans le train qui les
années justement par de l'autre côté de
la frontière et que nous avons eu à
l'époque sur Selvigny était en campagne
électorale une dénonciation très forte
de notre
intrusion sur le territoire italien et
donc on a réglé c'est plutôt mon
prédécesseur qui a réglé le problème en
créant ces brigades
de billes nationalité qui permet de
chacun de respecter la souveraineté de
ces pays mais j'ai compris dans votre
intervention que la question n'était pas
totalement sur la brigade Franco
italienne donc je pense que c'est mis
notre transition écologique qui pourra
mieux le mieux vous répondre sur la
plainte
je voudrais tout à fait raison Madame
moi je veux vous dire que je partage
vous n'avez pas eu d'agacement et moi
j'ai un agacement
les services de police gendarmerie ne
peuvent pas refuser une plainte
et non seulement il va falloir fuser
mais ils peuvent pas la refuser quand
quelqu'un est accompagné de la personne
de son choix qui est majeure c'est à
dire un avocat mais pas parce que les
avocats sont souvent majeurs mais mais
pas que l'avocat c'est-à-dire on peut
être accompagner n'importe qui donc moi
j'ai rappelé j'ai fait j'ai pris
moi-même une instruction que j'ai signé
personnellement ce qui est rare pour les
services de police pour rappeler à
chacune des policiers et chacun des
policiers de gendarmes de France que
quand un citoyen ou même un étranger
même s'il n'a pas de papier se présente
à ça gendarmerie on doit prendre sa
plainte
et on doit être accompagné des personnes
de son choix notamment dans les
violences conjugales on doit même
lorsque les locaux sont petits parce
qu'on m'a expliqué plein d'excuses le
code est d'ailleurs on a fait simplifier
monsieur député pour expliciter la
présence de l'avocat moi je le répéter
l'avocat c'est dès la première heure de
rentrer dans le commissariat ou dans le
regard de gendarmerie donc il y a des
services de pays ces gendarmerie pour
plein de raisons
pas que des raisons de non
professionnels et parfois pour des
habitudes qui refusent des plaintes et
quand j'étais mère ça m'agacé beaucoup
que les gens me disent j'ai essayé de
porter plainte on m'a dit non alors
après il est tout à fait vrai que pour
avoir une bonne réponse pénale il vaut
mieux avoir des éléments qui permettent
que cette plainte soit une plainte
probante bon alors on peut améliorer un
certain nombre de choses il est pas
normal qu'un service de police madame
franchement votre plante si vous
souhaitez mais sachez que si vous avez
par exemple le numéro de votre téléphone
portable c'est quand même mieux pour
qu'on puisse récupérer éventuellement la
personne qui voulait piquer ou si vous
avez la plaque d'immatriculation de
voiture c'est mieux que de dire je me
suis fait voler ma voiture parce que
c'est un peu vague vous voyez mais c'est
pas pour autant que ce travail de
renseignement soit incompatible avec le
fait quelqu'un qui vous dise je ne parle
pas plainte alors aujourd'hui comment ça
se passe parce que si je peux me
permettre vous avez dit une petite
bêtise dans la procédure d'aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui il y a une pré plainte en
ligne qui est possible que contrôler
violences contre les biens donc pas
contre les personnes et contre X
c'est-à-dire contre une personne que
vous ne connaissez pas donc vous pouvez
le faire à n'importe quelle heure du
jour et de la nuit sur toutes les sur
tous les cambriolages tous les vols de
voitures mais c'est la pré plainte c'est
à dire que vous enregistrez aujourd'hui
c'est 50% des prêt plaintes je vais
prendre votre question madame c'est 50%
des plaintes désormais dans les
commissades Île-de-France par exemple
c'est des gens qui ont déjà fait leur
déclarations de pré plainte du coup le
service de police va falloir répondre il
manque tel ou tel ou telle chose venez
avec celle-là et puis quand on fera la
plainte en direct qu'est-ce qu'on essaie
de faire on va faire la plainte en ligne
donc après plainte mais ça pour ça il me
faut une disposition législative donc il
faut voter le texte que je vous présente
sinon on va pas y arriver donc il y a la
plainte en ligne la plainte en ligne
c'est ce sera toujours que pour les
biens parce que entre les personnes on a
besoin devant les personnes je peux pas
dire mon mari mais attendez je vous
explique je peux pas dire mon mari m'a
tapé j'ai des bleus et je vais faire une
plainte en ligne parce que c'est il y a
des questions réponses qui doivent se
poser donc après la plainte en ligne
directement sur l'ordinateur elle se
fait sans interaction avec un service de
police que sur les biens ça c'est
premier point c'est quand même plus de
50 % de la délinquance ensuite donc ça
ça libère du temps d'enquêteur et ça
permet de mieux vous accueillir côté
violence contre les personnes qui sont
avouées le plus grave deuxièmement quand
les gens c'est des gens se contre les
personnes on va accepter dans la loi
locmin une disposition pour la plainte
en ligne numérique visio c'est à dire
que vous pourrez demain en 2023 déposez
une plainte mais parce que vous avez pas
envie de bouger parce que ça vous fait
peur d'aller d'un endroit de pas croiser
votre harceleur je ne sais quoi d'autre
de dire voilà je prends rendez-vous télé
en visio avec le service de police là il
vous voit et vous pouvez lui montrer un
certain nombre de choses il peut
discuter ou poser des questions avec
vous bien dans le dans le les
questionnaires désormais sur les
violences conjugales vous avez vu il y a
beaucoup de questions qui sont posées
par les services de police qui peuvent
pas se faire sur un questionnaire écrit
et donc on répond à la fois votre
demande plein de temps en ligne pour
toutes les violences contre les biens
plates en visio possible contre les
violences également aux personnes voilà
et on espère effectivement que ça
contribuera à la facilité à désengorger
les commissariats les gendarmerie à
pouvoir évidemment libérer la parole
dans un certain nombre un certain nombre
de cas je pense qu'il ne reste plus
qu'une question c'est les eqtf
et titre de séjour pour Monsieur Tallier
et oui il y avait monsieur pont j'ai
oublié monsieur bon je ne peux pas
oublier monsieur pont
[Musique]
aujourd'hui pour la loi immigration on
va essayer en tout cas on a proposé au
Conseil d'État qui manifestement
l'a accepté mais évidemment un avis sera
rendu sur le texte on proposera que
lorsqu'il y a un refus de demande
d'asile il est concomitamment un une
UDF qui se mise en tout cas un refus de
séjour et une expulsion prononcée parce
qu'aujourd'hui le parcours du demandeur
d'asile elle est délirante expression
pour ceux qui ont vraiment
besoin d'asile comme pour ceux qui
détournent le droit d'asile puisqu'on
donne 70% de refus malgré les 130 000
demandes d'asile en France et
contrairement à ce que j'entends on
n'est pas particulièrement ouvert sur
l'asile donc le problème c'est que les
gens qui ont vraiment besoin d'asile qui
sont vraiment pour chasser qui sont
condamnés en raison de leur orientation
sexuelle ou de nos politiques ils
attendent très longtemps avant d'avoir
une réponse pourquoi parce que il y a
beaucoup de gens qui demandent l'asile
dont une grande partie détourne l'asile
alors que c'est un immigration c'est je
veux dire régulière et donc ce qu'on
fait c'est qu'on va réduire les délais
l'État a réduit beaucoup les délais mais
ce qui n'a pas été réduit souvent
c'était la juriste la justice
administrative pourquoi parce qu'on sait
tous que les tribunes administratifs
sont engorgés par le droit des étrangers
plus de 50% plus de 60 % selon les ta et
la CNDA mais plus de temps parce qu'elle
a beaucoup de dossiers et donc on a une
réforme de de la justice administrative
en lien parfait avec le Conseil d'État
on aura l'occasion de débattre qui
permettra de juger plus rapidement de
donner l'asile plus rapidement à des
gens qui n'ont vraiment besoin des
accueillir des intégrer qui puissent
travailler je rappelle que dans un asile
peuvent pas travailler quand ils
arrivent sur le soin national ce qui les
renforce dans une forme de de pauvreté
difficultés et puis de l'autre côté de
dire très rapidement nom à des gens
qu'on veut pas sur le sol national et de
leur dire bah voilà c'est non et c'est
pas possible de rester sur le territoire
national parce qu'aujourd'hui quand on
leur dit non à l'asile du coup il
demande le titre de séjour
et puis après il faut un recours quand
on le refuse dans le titre de séjour
puis après ils attaques le qtf donc il y
a jusqu'à 12 procédures alors que main
du droit C4 voilà donc on aura
l'occasion d'en parler mais
effectivement c'est tout à fait le sujet
et en vous répondant je me posais la
question de savoir qui était la question
de Monsieur pont
pardon
ah oui alors oui je devais marqué
j'arrive pas à me lire mais j'ai marqué
ponce RS je m'inquiétais
non de malade plutôt là en l'occurrence
la chère docteur
alors moi je suis pour qu'on préserve je
les ai préserver les CRS des plages où
les gendarmes mobiles des plages donc je
vous réponds oui mais ma grand-mère m'a
disait tout ce qui est après mais
n'existe pas bon
pas en 2023 et pas du tout en 2024
pourquoi parce que j'ai deux grands
événements sportifs à organiser et que
mes CRS si vous permettez de dire mais
CRS on va bien sûr les mettre pour les
événements sportifs de l'été alors un
peu 2023 parce que c'est septembre mais
il y a une sorte de congé il faut
préparer il y a les équipes c'est
compliqué et 24 voilà donc je l'ai déjà
dit Homer je les prépare je les prépare
on va garder puisque c'était prévu
d'être supprimé la position des CRS et
gendarmes mobiles sur les plages je
pense que cet été c'est très bien passé
y compris dans des villes dites
difficiles à Marseille par exemple et
une baisse de la délinquance extrêmement
importante le long des plages sur ces
sur ces questions là notamment sur les
rodéo nautiques qui ont empoisonné la
ville de Marseille en
2020 pardon mais là pour 23 24 vous
comprendrez monsieur le député qu'on va
pas pouvoir le mettre à disposition on
prévient assez tôt les mers alors ça
peut être des brigades territoriales de
gendarmerie qui le fasse on peut
imaginer des choses plus innovantes mais
ça ne sera pas des CRS et gendarmes
mobiles mais ils reviendront des 25 dès
qu'on aura organisé les Jeux Olympiques
bien monsieur le ministre merci pour
cette audition très complète et pour
tous ceux qui auraient été frustrés par
la durée de l'audition on aura une
audition budgétaire normalement à la
mi-novembre et on aura une octobre
pardon non mais j'anticipé puisque au
mois de novembre on aura certainement
une audition pour la loop me ce qui fait
que on vous reverra très vite et
intervalle régulier merci encore